Ah, ah, ah.
Hello everybody!
Hello, hello, hello.
Hello, hello.
Let me take a sippy.
Thank you for the five gifts.
Hat.
Where's hat?
Sorry, I'm getting adjusted.
Um, hello!
Welcome to... Welcome back?
Maybe it's a dredge.
Swamp goals!
Thank you so much for the five gifts.
Am I okay?
I'm okay.
Um...
Maybe...
Once a month, there's about a strange...
Flow of spiritual energy that disrupts the ghostly realm.
And, uh...
This time it's particularly...
It's scary this time!
Amazing with Nimi last Friday.
I hope you guys do more collabs in the future, please.
I would love to do more collabs with Nimi.
Nightmare with Nikima!
Thank you!
Glad you liked it.
No, no, it's spiritual energy.
What are you guys talking about?
Spiritual energy.
Anyway.
But because of that, I'm a little...
I'm a little off today.
A little more lethargic.
A little more...
That.
So...
Where did the BGM go?
Can I give you chocolate?
You could always...
Offer it as an offering, you know?
But I was like, I'm feeling a little...
Maybe I just wanna fish.
Maybe I just wanna fish a little bit.
When I scrape my knee, I let spiritual energy out and my ghost too.
You have an ectoplasm?
Fishing?
I was fishing.
I was literally me.
If this is your first time watching Dredge today...
There's like a story, but not really.
So there's really just like some quests that we have to do, but mostly we're just kinda fishing.
So you're kinda... There's not really...
Yeah, it's more like a mystery.
Yeah, there's like...
We're fishing and sometimes we get some demonic fish.
That's about it, I think.
Have you seen they're adding friendly ghasts?
Oh my gosh, yes!
Before!
Before I streamed yesterday.
I was watching the Minecraft live.
And so I saw it all happening live.
And I saw... Did you guys see the friendly ghasts?
Oh my gosh, they're so stinking cute.
They're so cute!
You go to the nether and you go and you get a little like...
Ghast...
Jerky.
And then you throw the jerky in the water and you rehydrate it.
And then it becomes a little baby ghast.
And then it grows up to be a big ghast.
And then you're gonna... Oh my gosh.
It's actually...
It's so funny because, you know, I like to put on...
As toxic as it may be, I like to watch the live chats and those sorts of things.
Because they're so all over the place.
It's such a fascinating thing to watch.
But even with this...
Like, usually people just be like, Oh, it's like watching the game awards live chats and everything too.
They'll be like, Oh, when is new Fortnite skin?
Oh, give us... Give me...
Fortnite, Roblox, Robux...
Whatever.
The eyes of cringe.
Yeah, skip, skip, L, take, L, L.
They love spamming that.
But this time with the ghasts, people were eating it up.
They were like, This is awesome.
This is so awesome.
I get to have waifu ghast.
My dream has come...
Waifu?
Bloodborne PC.
No, GTA 6.
Yeah, it's always those same comments.
You heard them.
The man did not stutter.
But yeah, people were like really into...
The ghast thing.
It's so awesome because you can ride on them.
And it's almost like creative mode.
Where you're like...
That's the reason why so many people use creative mode, right?
Just to be able to like...
Fly and build stuff with ease.
But with this, you can just sit on the ghast and move around as if you're in creative mode.
And like...
Build that way.
It's so awesome.
It is well known that fish are laden with myriad vitamins and essential oils that aid in the recovery from the sick.
Probably, I think.
Gotta be.
Thank you.
Thanks so much for the super chat, Sk8ly.
So...
I'm very excited.
There was one part that was making me laugh.
Because after they announced that, people were like...
Okay, when are we gonna get the update?
Which this I agree upon.
I agree on this because it's like...
People really want an update.
Sorry, this is not Minecraft talk, but...
I forgot to mention it yesterday.
Um...
People really want an update for the end.
Right?
Like...
Because all there is are sometimes the boats and that's it.
There's nothing in the end.
At all.
And so...
People were like...
Hey, can we please get an update for the end?
Can we please get an update for the end?
Please get an update for the end.
And...
There was one comment.
You always can tell when it's like kids in the chat.
It's so funny.
But there was one comment that was just like...
Everyone!
Please spam!
Update the end, please!
Until they hear our cries!
3, 2, 1, go!
I'm like, yeah, that's exactly what...
That kid, it was me.
I wrote that in chat.
And...
It's so funny.
They're trying to...
Yeah, they're trying to have a revolution in the chat.
They're just like...
Everyone...
Yeah, hot dog!
Feel better being...
Thank you!
I saw a clip about you being into robot women.
The YouTube recommended me a video about something called...
Martial Machine Maiden.
Thought I should share in case you haven't heard of it.
I haven't.
Hold on, I'm gonna look it up.
Martial Machine Maiden.
This is so on my alley.
Thank you.
Wait, what is happening?
Everyone!
Please spam!
Mint is cute!
No!
Black Knight, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Suckers, those cries only fuel the devs.
Wait, in like, spite or...
Also, Uni, thank you so much for the 5 gifted.
Thank you.
And Jesse, thank you so much for the 5 gifted.
Also, thank you!
I like the idea of vanilla shaders.
Oh yes!
That's another thing they added.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Kids are cool, Jack.
They added in-game shaders.
Which is huge too, I think.
Right?
So, sometimes shaders can really lag.
And also, if you want to use shaders, if you're so used to shaders, but you want to use the most updated Minecraft...
Big news!
Big Minecraft news.
I also have big news!
Sorry, this is only for Metal Gear people.
I was playing Peace Walker this morning.
And of course this had to happen off stream.
I have some...
Did I say...
I said Peace Walker, right?
I was playing Peace Walker this morning.
I have several news.
First...
I got Nemi Nightmare.
I got a tape here.
I got Nemi Nightmare as our first new recruit announcement.
How do you say it?
I got Nemi.
Thanks Nemi, welcome to MSF.
And then, our next announcement.
Announcement.
Leech...
Has joined...
MSF!
That's our guy.
That's Leech right there.
Leech!
Of course I had to get him off stream.
I'm so sad.
Sorry, that means a lot to anybody who's been following Metal Gear and Peace Walker and stuff.
For those who want a little bit more context.
I played Metal Gear Solid, Peace Walker before.
And in the game you recruit people, as you can see.
They all have different animal names.
And in the past, I once got a guy named Leech.
And I was like, Leech?
His name is Leech?
And his stats sucked.
And I was like, you are a literal leech upon our base.
What?
Who are you?
And I, you know, of course.
Of course I grew attached to our poor simple Leech.
And then...
And then I sent him off into combat and Leech died on the battlefield.
Boss, can you teach me how to reload?
Yeah, that's what Leech says.
And so, yes.
Now we have Leech back.
Anyway, shall we dredge?
So...
We are back.
Oh my gosh, that's right.
I'm trying to do a research part.
There was one more that I was trying to get, I believe.
You think Leech likes tortilla chips?
Absolutely.
Leech probably is like a vacuum and just...
Everything.
You know, just like a leech would.
Silver, welcome to membership.
Masakichi, welcome to membership.
Thank you guys, thank you so much.
Jet engine, yes.
So, this game is a...
As you can see, it's an inventory management fishing simulator.
Right now we are searching for relics.
Such as these.
Which...
We went to Gale Cliffs and I got scared.
Right now we are at...
Somewhere.
Right now we are...
This one is a hard task.
Deliver rotting kangaroo.
Right now we are at Stellar Basin.
Stellar Basin.
I have not been to the Twisted Strand or Devil's Spine yet.
And I'm just noticing that all of these names kind of sound like a Neil Breen movie.
Like Twisted Strand.
Stellar Basin.
What do you and Nemi's girly pop sugar epic couples name be?
Mini Nightome or Ninto Fantmare or Nomptmare Night.
These are so cursed.
Hashtag eyes on Breen.
Wait, what is eyes on Breen?
What's that?
Get well soon, Johnson.
Thanks, nine.
Faithful fishing.
It's a Red Letter Media reference?
Wait, I know Red Letter Media.
Hashtag eyes on Breen.
I don't remember that though.
Oh gosh.
It's from the Breen Watch Along.
Red Letter Media does a lot of Neil Breen coverage.
Yeah, I know.
I love Red Letter Media.
Mike Stacloss is my oshi.
I was literally watching, what was it?
Oh gosh.
The review of Possession.
I was watching that.
He sure is.
I love Red Letter Media.
Okie dokie.
So we have this X.
Oh sorry, my head is blocking it.
This X here, that is one of the cursed objects we need to get.
But we need C4.
We need something explosive.
And then there's something in here.
Not quite sure how to get this one yet.
We have not been to Twisted Strand or Devil's Spine yet.
We probably have to go back to the morrows and then...
So that we don't get caught in the...
In the night time.
At night, things get real spooky you guys.
Hi.
Hello.
Watch Mini Minto, watching Minto and the Mintoception.
Wait, Mini Minto?
Where?
But I'm trying to collect these research parts.
Oh, I have a message.
I forgot to read this.
Vessel SY Grand Prize.
Oaken Music Box.
Oh, Artifact Manifest.
Is this what he's trying to get?
Purchased from... Oh no, this is what he did get.
Purchased from the Ant Aquarian at Little Morrow for a bargain price.
Previously salvaged from an undisclosed shipwreck.
Has the letter J carved on the other's underside, otherwise in reasonable condition.
Has not been opened for fear of damaging the mechanism.
Pending inspection by locksmith.
One more month.
Wow.
Almost one year.
Oh, the Minto plushie.
Oh, my cursor?
Yeah, my cursor.
I got it finally to work where it doesn't...
I can turn off my computer and it doesn't reset to my normal cursor.
It's forever Minto cursor.
4-4.
Spooky day.
But I actually... I...
I initially graduated on 4-3, so I think I'll celebrate then.
Like a combination.
4-4-4.
It's like a combination.
I'm back.
Because I also, you know, came back on April 1st.
Hmm.
I'm still thinking about it.
4-2.
Wooden mask.
Carved wooden tribal mask said to bring good luck, fertility...
You guys can use that.
Good health, fortune, rain and protection from evil spirits.
You guys can really use this.
Traded for a pair of socks and a pocket watch chain.
12-piece tea set.
Bone china.
Six-time cup.
Six-time saucer.
Acquired from an eastern dealer.
Do not use.
And then a jar containing earth from a meteorite impact site allegedly.
My head is hiding the do not use, but I promise it says that.
Oh, fisherman's note.
When did I get this?
Deep sky, deep sky, deep forever.
Casket, seal, broken fog core.
This is so fog core.
Oh my god.
5 equals rise.
He knows.
Okay, spooky.
Alright.
Oh, encyclopedia.
I'm just gonna zoom through these so that we can...
You see, like, I got a lumpy guy.
All seeing caught.
Wisps are fine with fertility.
Plenty of pregnancies already.
Maybe.
I don't know.
Are you sure?
There's so many things in the morrow I still haven't gotten.
The morrows.
The morrows, the morrows.
And I've only discovered not even 20 out of at least 150.
One more to see to be a dredge fishing master is my destiny.
Upside down lumpy.
Thank you so much for the gift.
Thank you.
Okay.
It's a little late.
Hold on.
I'm gonna use this time since I'm close to the dock to kind of...
Oh, wait.
Fish.
We got a savage barracuda!
Alright.
That was so lucky.
Okay, now I'm gonna sleep.
What a savage.
I'm gonna take it.
I'm gonna...
I'm going to... What's the word?
Take it safe until I get used to the controls again.
Look at that guy!
It thrashes about ruinously.
Ruin... yeah.
Jaw is snapping and tearing its own flesh apart.
A body sundered by ravenous hatred.
Sell my fish before I sleep?
Oh, because they'll...
They'll... yeah.
They'll rot.
I love the sound of rain against the roof of my cabin.
Is there anything better?
I only have this.
But he sells for a pretty penny.
We'll sell it.
Otherwise he'll rot.
I don't think I can sell...
I'm gonna put these in my storage.
We'll sell these later.
My Ouroboros flag.
And my scrap.
Just in case something happens.
What was the floating dock again?
Oh, that's right.
This is this.
We are trying to get...
No, it's under the upgrades.
So we actually...
I could buy the last research part, you guys!
Should I?
I only have 376 and it's 350.
Do it!
Nah, they're plentiful.
That's how I feel.
But I'm like...
Would I be able to even buy the...
Money is meant to be spent.
Let's sleep.
And we'll think about it when we're on our way back to...
What do you call it?
The morrows, you know?
Good morning, Mito!
Alright.
It is...
Not this way.
This way?
Which direction?
Oh!
Oh my gosh, follow the lighthouse.
I see it!
I'm kinda bad at turning.
I see some fishy over there.
Something fishy over yonder.
But I should head back.
Oh, Detroit, thank you!
Buy a weekly happiness tax!
What are you talking about?
Thank you though, thank you!
Thank you so much for the Akasupa.
I really appreciate it.
Help me recover from surgery.
Oh my gosh, I hope you're feeling okay.
Is this a dock?
I can't tell.
I'm gonna dredge for...
Oh shoot, that's right.
Awesome.
Oh, we got some broken spectacles.
I shouldn't do too much though if we're trying to get back home.
Okay, we got a water bottle.
What are these minky sounds coming from?
I want to dredge.
That sounds so scary.
Okay, we'll boost.
It's so dark.
It's so peaceful here though, no?
Look, we're already halfway back.
I can fish a little.
Oh, nevermind.
I just noticed the time.
Nevermind.
Let's get home immediately.
Kookaburra.
The bird!
Will I make it?
I sure hope so.
I think so.
Oh, if anything, I can always stop here.
Oh gosh.
Guys, it's gonna get spooky.
It's about to get spooky.
Nah, I can make it.
I can make it.
It's about to get spooky.
Look, look, look, look.
Special fish.
What's that sound?
Freaky.
Wait.
The stone skin of this ray is molded around a black crystal shard.
The rock fragments articulate and grind together.
Gross.
We're docking.
Let's see.
Trader, I have some broken glasses.
And in my storage I have...
That's it?
Why were the glasses more expensive than the ring?
Oh wait.
Yeah.
See?
They're his.
Yeah.
He's like, oh my gosh.
These are worth so much because they're mine.
Alrighty.
Trying to decide what we want to do, guys.
We could always go to the Devil's Spine.
Sell the ray.
Oh yeah, yeah, we should.
Do you think... Oh, do you think it's gross now?
It's still fresh!
It's still fresh.
You can see it behind my head.
We'll sell him to the crazy guy here.
I don't think he...
Maybe we shouldn't sell it to him?
I guess we'll see.
Hi buddy.
Blinding headache today.
Did you come by yesterday?
I don't recall.
Anyway, what can I do for you?
153!
Nice.
Does this...
I don't know if I have this on my ship or not.
No.
It's fine.
Anyway.
I thought that was like an aesthetic or like a cosmetic.
That's the word.
Okey dokey.
Wait, what is it?
Research!
That's what I was thinking of.
Research the engine.
And it's this guy.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Sorry, I'm remembering everything.
It is a cosmetic for the painter.
We can give it to him later.
Oh, the hull damage!
Excuse me, ma'am.
Thank you.
My money.
We also picked up this message.
September 14th, 1927.
I have not written in a few days.
I have been afflicted with some strange chill which conspires to fog my brain.
I cannot seem to keep warm no matter what I do.
The ink has run for some lines here and they are illegible.
While most of what they hauled up was junk, they eventually came up with a large wooden casket?
A hush came over the crew at such a tantalizing discovery.
I remember the next moments with excruciating clarity.
He pried it open easily.
The buckling boards cracked and groaned with relief as they splintered apart.
Crimson cloth spilled out onto the deck.
The crashing waves rose to fill my ears.
I hear them still.
He stared down into the open casket, then turned to me.
In his eyes I saw the void.
The page has been torn off here.
Dio?
We got a vampire running around too?
This thing is amazing looking, the Shard Ray!
Wait, he's so awesome!
He actually looks like a...
He actually looks kind of like a...
Like a mecha something, you know?
So cool.
I love Metal Gear Ray.
Okay.
I think what I'm gonna do...
Let's go to Steel Point.
See if we can sleep there yet.
Because if we can...
Then we can like kind of fish around in that area.
Until night.
You know?
Gale Cliffs?
I'm so scared though.
I kind of want to go to each corner first.
Because clearly we're missing some stuff.
Like I need to find something to blow up.
New horrors await us.
Exactly!
Hello!
Ding dong!
And I haven't really been in this little area so much yet.
See?
We can rest.
And we can research and everything.
So we'll just kind of stay around in the Steel Point area.
Until sleep.
We can fish.
And we can grab scraps and things.
I think you're swell.
Thank you!
Really?
You think I'm swell?
Alright.
We got all the scraps there.
Thank you so much for the 5 gifted.
Thank you!
I saw some fishies over here.
What are you?
What's your fish?
Blue mackerel.
Did it say practically worthless?
Yes.
We also have this guy, right?
Who lets us know...
Oh!
I see.
I haven't caught that yet.
That's fun.
What's that over there?
I haven't caught that yet either!
Okay.
Good, good, good.
This game is dangerous.
It encouraged me to go swimming in the ocean.
Now I'm covered in jellyfish stink.
Oh no!
Whatever could be the thing to heal your...
Holy moly!
Oh my gosh!
This guy is huge.
Wait a second.
I think I messed up.
Wait.
Scrap?
Oh gosh!
He's huge!
Okay.
She doesn't bite, does she?
I want to catch the other fish over there too.
She doesn't bite.
Shoot!
Look!
That's where we're going next, no?
Yeah.
Devil's spine.
What should we do, guys?
The fish will rot.
But we can still get pennies for them, right?
I would sell, but where?
Builder, please!
Thanks again for helping me move out here.
I've managed to get myself set up now.
I found this while I'm packing.
You should take it.
Engineer's companion.
Oh, we got a new book!
Nice.
Do we ever need to use the dock or store stuff here?
Store?
He'll die in storage too though.
I don't think I can make it back.
I mean, I could just go.
But there's no fridge up there.
Upgrading, alright.
Floor it!
We're gonna risk it for the biscuit, everybody.
Yeah, it's just right here, but it's still scary.
I'm a baby wimp, okay?
Would you please...
Moe moe kyun, my daily multivitamin.
Of course!
One second.
Wait, it was supposed to be...
Oh, there we go.
Brute squid!
Nasty.
Alright, we sell.
Oishikunare!
Moe moe kyun!
Now your multivitamin is very delicious.
Right?
I didn't mess it up, right?
Oh baby, we got almost $700!
Tentacle sprout from a glowing core inside a gelatinous sack.
Other cores lay dormant alongside.
Okay.
Goodnight!
The spell just tripled the nutrition.
Like I said, I'm gonna be a little bit of a baby until we get a few more upgrades, I think.
There's a DLC that adds an ice biome and a fridge!
That you can visit at any point.
I did see that there were DLCs for this game, but honestly...
I'm not gonna lie, the reviews for them were kinda mid.
I was surprised.
I was like, oh, okay.
I guess some people didn't really like them.
Iron rig is good, the others are eh.
Ah, I see.
I'm gonna also...
Sailfish.
Blue mackerel.
Oh, I guess it was also a sailfish.
Ice.
If you like the base game, then they are okay.
I like how comfy this is so much.
I was like, this is kind of a perfect game for like...
You know, midday or for...
Sunday.
Sunday afternoon.
For me at least, it's a Sunday afternoon, so I'm just...
I'm just vibing.
Oh, the DLCs are on sale?
How long has this seemed...
Black fin tuna, that's new.
Okay.
What's over here in this...
Spooky...
Spine world.
Marshy blows.
Woah, it's...
Really orange.
What the...
Oh, this looks...
Okay.
Why is it so orange here?
Oh, it's...
Is that thing moving?
No.
Oh, it's...
It's like volcanic here.
Just...
Like the water is glowing.
Hello!
I'm docking here.
A man meets you as you dock.
Bracing himself against the wind and spray.
Rapturous day of fresh disciple carried to me atop the waves.
Come ashore, weak thing, and rest your weary soul.
Alright.
Hey, I'm docking here.
Your arrival is providence from the deep itself.
I have been calling, and now you are the answer.
The rite of purification is almost at hand.
And you are to be my replacement?
What's wrong with your arm, buddy?
Are you turning into a fish?
I'm listening.
Your trial begins immediately.
Tell me, what does your spirit seek?
We can have happiness, sadness, or emptiness.
A cigarette.
Tough choice.
Emptiness?
I was thinking that too.
Yes, a pure vessel.
Only those devoid of morality can ascend past it.
And your flesh, what does it crave?
Salt.
Pain is a trick of the flesh.
Do not surrender to it.
I just landed in Korea!
Watched Mufasa like I promised.
Bye-bye song shouldn't be real.
Half up with dredge.
I'm glad you had a safe flight, ducky.
Bye-bye.
You're gonna make it go bye-bye.
Finally, what does the world deserve?
I'll give the world everything.
In a way, it deserves all that is washed ashore.
Freely given from the deep.
But no more than that.
That's not everything.
The trial is concluded.
You still have much to learn, but that knowledge will be delivered to you in time.
Now, your role, as my initiate, is to act as Herald of the Purge.
Just as I was for the one before me.
The nearby spires blaze with eternal fire, yet the stone hearths of these three idols lie barren and void.
Are we purging?
Retrieve three fathomless flames from the crags behind us and ignite the crucibles.
Visit the shrines of the deep.
I will mark them.
They will offer further guidance.
And I must provide no more.
Wow, idols.
Which statue do you want to look at?
Oh, we don't have anything to give them, so...
Stone columns.
These stone columns of the temple are carved with ancient pictures and text.
Which carving do you want to look at?
The small creatures?
The carving shows a swarm of small fish surrounding a boat.
The ravenous children.
Alone they are nothing.
Together they summon her.
Okay, so we should watch out for the small children because...
What?
I mean, a female?
A female?
Her?
Beneath these words, somebody has added a crudely scratched note.
Do not let them grip you.
Burn them away.
Okay, the large eyeless beast.
A carving is of a large fish with crossed out eyes.
The unseeing mother.
When the starving cannot eat, she approaches.
Aiken!
Thanks for 11 months!
Beneath these words, somebody has added a crudely scratched note.
Blind, but can hear her children.
Avoid at all costs.
Okay, the bubbling vent.
A breath of salvation.
It burns those that mean harm.
Only the pure remain.
Beneath these words, somebody added a crudely... No, protection.
Follow the magma.
Find them.
Seems bad news.
What is it?
Oh, I'm looking for sunken relics, yeah.
Relics, you say?
Perhaps one such as this?
He pulls an antique pocket watch from inside his robe.
Droplets of sea spray crackle and seethe in the air around it.
You are drawn to it too, I see.
It found me during my rite of proving as I scavenge for creatures of power.
Donotimus Primal, welcome to my vision.
Thank you.
It sacked at my spirit when I first recovered it, but I came to appreciate its strange nourishment with time.
As will you.
When the ritual is prepared, it will be yours to carry forth.
Oh, so we have to do the ritual to get the relic.
Okay.
Are there any others that share your beliefs?
There are pretenders.
Failures that make a mockery of the deep.
I tried correcting their ways.
But I soon saw that they had lost the path.
I left them to their ceaseless hunger.
A monkey skull?
What are you talking about?
He looks like a fish more than anything.
What's that scroll you're holding?
I found it.
At the end of my other life, it washed ashore, as all great gifts do.
It took some time for me to decipher the runes.
It speaks of an incomprehensible door.
And those wretched, twisted fish that swam through, their flesh is the closest thing to a key.
What am I supposed to be doing?
You are to prepare the ritual.
You must light the stone with the three fathomless flames.
Okay, see you.
We can sleep.
Yeah, we'll sleep.
We can probably go... I think I see a light over on the other side.
So I imagine that might be the traveling merchant and we can probably...
My eyes!
Holy moly!
We can probably...
Holy cow.
Buy the research stuff from her.
Bolt of cloth.
I'll take it.
Hello!
Oh, Alfredo, thank you!
I'm going to be starting a new job tomorrow, so I thought it would be a good time to thank you for all the amazing streams.
Thank you!
Good luck with your new job!
I tried.
I tried, everybody.
What's that sound?
Beware of the children.
Beware of children.
I'm not ready to be a father.
Are those the children?
Those look like children.
I'm not ready!
I don't want to be a father!
Please!
I'm docking.
Leave me alone.
Charred pontoon.
She's a dead bee.
No!
They're not my kids!
Please repair.
Those are bad things.
350?
I'm buying it.
I'm buying it!
Wait, can we research here?
Yes we can!
You guys.
Huge.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5!
Now...
Shipyard.
300 each!
I only have 350.
We got a shot more.
Now you can crash into stuff even faster!
Yeah,
now to afford them.
I'll hold off on it.
For now.
Wait, why?
Oh, I guess because I... Wait.
Where did this one come from?
We still have the best light I think that we can get.
Yeah.
Okay.
Wait, what is this?
The final state of all living things.
When did I get this?
Oh, a fish rotted.
What fish?
The worthless fish.
We truly was worthless.
Will you buy it?
I don't think she will.
Fingerton!
Thanks for the five gifted!
Thank you!
Oh wait, my bad.
Two cloths, one...
Okay, I need some more wood.
We have... Wait, do I have wood in storage or no?
I don't think so.
Nope.
I'm scared of this area.
I'm leaving.
The little guys aren't gonna find me, right?
I'm just gonna fish here.
If we just non-stop fish...
What the heck is this thing?
I like how each area kind of has their own...
Whoa!
Kind of got their own little mini-game going on.
I forgot to put that in storage.
I bought some fish from the store that the shopkeeper said you caught for him.
Kind of purple and has a few extra eyes.
But it's pretty tasty.
Thanks again for playing such an awesome game.
I hope it fills you with lots of nutrients and power.
These guys might be worth a bajillion dollars.
Who knows?
Oops.
Oh, we finished our book.
It's quiet.
Too quiet.
How much are these?
21 each.
Alright, we got 105 dollars.
Storage with you.
I'm feeling like I can't do anything.
I don't know.
I feel like I go to one area and I get scared and I can't do anything.
Time for new engine.
I think that's what I'm gonna do for now.
Is this a fish?
No, I think I should avoid that.
There's fish over here.
It's so red here.
It's hard to see.
What are you?
A snake mackerel.
Yeah, let's just keep farming a little bit.
So chill.
It's only 10.
I see more over there.
We'll go...
Where was it?
There.
Hopefully we don't run into any children.
I'm not good with kids.
Oh no, I don't have the equipment.
That sucks.
Let's keep going.
Telescope.
Yeah, that might be good to use so that we can...
There's more snake mackerel.
Some rough seas over here, huh?
Snake mackerel.
I can't see anything.
I hope you guys don't get seasick.
Oh, is she gonna blow?
We'll just get the more snake mackerel, I suppose.
Where are we anyway?
We're on a teeny little island.
A mysterious place.
Can I dock there?
I can't tell.
It's like I'm being drawn to it.
You see the wind?
It's like blowing me over there.
Oh!
Tattered mackerel.
A tangle of ribbons.
What's that sound?
Anyway...
Oh, it's gone now.
Interesting.
Very interesting.
But how does it taste?
There's an idol there.
A forgotten idol.
I wouldn't forget you.
You'd be my oshi.
Let's head back.
She graduated.
Don't say that.
Don't say that about my oshi.
I have so many...
Actually at this point, all the music...
I have an mp3 player in my car.
And pretty much every...
Every group on it now is now a disbanded group.
Like a graduated idol or a disbanded group or...
Something.
It's just how it is.
I don't think there's a single one on there that's...
That's not...
I can afford two now!
Should I sell one of these?
I don't think I should sell it.
I think I should just uninstall it.
No.
Symptom of getting old.
Nah, I suppose so.
You can't sell the peculiar one.
You can sell the other.
I see, I see.
So I'm gonna uninstall you.
Put you in storage.
And then...
We shall...
Shipyard.
Gonna buy two.
Install.
She only has one.
Maybe she'll have another one in the morning.
You're our spooky ghost ship crew captain phantom.
Oh my goodness.
It's like a fish.
Art of the silver tongue.
Oh, we got another book.
Thank you.
Perfect.
Okay.
How much was the other one?
18.9.
Okay, so this is technically faster.
I have 30 books left.
That's good.
Now we...
Do our book.
What is this?
Art of the silver tongue.
I wonder what it will grant us.
Oh, we got a message.
I forgot.
Is he a fish?
Fish.
Fish love story.
Like the statues.
I have a question for anybody if you've played this before.
Are there multiple endings?
Are there multiple endings of this game?
Yes.
So I guess it just really depends on what we...
want to get.
What the hell is that thing?
Gale Cliffs?
That's not where we're at.
I feel we are in a scary area.
And I would like to leave.
Oh wow, we're really fast now.
What's that sound?
I think we should go.
Lighthouse?
I think we should leave.
Potentially.
Just the wind.
Where are we anyway?
We're heading over to Steel Point.
Thank you Luna!
Keeping silly and green.
Thank you!
I'll keep being green.
One thing I do want to do is try and find...
Okay, so if I imagine...
I want to find the C4 stuff.
I keep saying C4.
I think it's C4?
I actually don't know what it is.
But I want to find the stuff that we need...
to...
to blow stuff up, you know?
What's that light over there?
What is this?
I didn't realize I was just heading home.
Probably TNT.
Consider upgrading your ship capacity first.
Alright, hold on.
We could do that.
Then I...
Um...
Want to go see what we need for it.
I do need to find more wood and like supplies and stuff.
We can do that since I'm just right over here.
We're right on the coast, so...
There's no biggie.
There's fish.
Fish.
Big fish.
What are you?
I think I've gotten him before.
Yeah, we should upgrade our capacity, huh?
Oh, I'm home!
Not here.
It would be under the dry dock, right?
Net space...
Engine space...
Oh my god, we could hold two more engines!
That'd be insane.
So I need a new hull basically, right?
Oh my goodness.
Okay, we're gonna go have to find a lot of supplies.
We're gonna have to go find a bunch of supplies then.
Okay, okay.
I'm gonna rest.
We'll make it daytime.
We'll leave.
I don't... Wait, I didn't have anything, right?
Nope.
I have nothing to my name.
I have nothing.
I am Mint Phantom.
Um, we'll go to...
It would be a good place to...
I guess just...
Finding little islands and...
Like, crash...
Crashed areas, maybe?
I'm gonna head towards the gale...
Cliffs.
And maybe over there.
Wait, what's this?
Go flounder.
Be quick, past Captain Mint's personal fishing shotgun.
There might be some stuff over here.
Unless I have already...
Gotten it.
Let's check.
Uh...
There's...
Some sort of material...
Or not material, but...
I guess we can...
What's that over there?
Have I gone that way?
Sorry, I'm so all over the place.
I'm all over the place, you guys.
There's just so much we could do.
I just have to make up my mind.
Yeah, I've already scavenged this place before.
It's called sailing.
We'll get some more money at least from this.
We got an old chain.
Very cool.
Have I been here?
We'll search around these islands.
There was more on this island, there was.
What is here?
Is
that...
The wind, did you see that?
It's so mysterious.
So mysterious.
Why was it leading me back over there?
Spoopy.
What is here?
Hello.
Otacon?
What the hell?
Would you step out of the way for a moment?
You're in my shot.
Move to the side.
A few seconds later, the photographer sighs in exasperation and mutters...
Oh, sorry.
Sorry, ma'am.
No, this simply won't do.
What's the matter?
The angle of this lens is all wrong.
I'll never get a close-up shot of anything with this.
And the others, I fear they were lost overboard.
She sighs again and looks off to the west.
I was sailing from Stellar Basin, you see, squeezing...
Oh.
Squeezing my bums, is what I thought she was gonna say.
That's what I've been doing playing this game.
Squeezing my boat through a narrow gap between two islands, and then I crashed into some coral.
I thought I heard something in the water behind me, so I dared not stop.
So if you were to...
If you were able to retrieve the lenses for me, let me see.
She rummages through what a few belongings survived the trip.
You guys don't squeeze your bum when you're, like, stressed?
I have a spare camera here that I won't need.
You're welcome to it.
If you can find those lenses.
I'll mark on your map where I think I lost them.
Oh, cool!
Okay.
Thanks, lady.
We're looking for wood.
Here we go.
No!
Whoa,
this must be worth...
Oh, ouch.
Ow!
Bag of doubloons!
Just get actual money.
I'm gonna look around the rest of this.
We can sleep here, so we can just kind of...
Anything else on this island?
Nothing?
If I have a bag of doubloons...
Is that not money itself?
Curious.
Curious!
Depends.
There was stuff where the wind was blowing.
Yeah, we'll head back over there.
It's old coins.
We're modern technologists now.
We don't need your old coins.
Coins.
So it was right over here, no?
The wind blew.
How do I use the camera?
Oh, I guess we have to probably get the lenses first before we can use...
What was that sound?
Oh!
Did I not explore here?
Familiar looking hole.
Looking...
Oh, that's right!
We only... I don't think we explored everything here, no?
In the cabin...
I remember looking in the electrical equipment.
Cupboards, drawers...
Loose floorboard...
Electrical equipment, yeah, yeah.
Go back...
Cargo...
We've already emptied the cargo.
What?
Why is it still shiny then?
Why did it still direct me over here?
Oh, wait.
You see some red particles floating here?
What are those red particles?
What are those?
Can we fish here?
Disturbed water.
Oh, I don't have the right equipment.
No!
Interesting.
There's this over here.
Where are we anyway?
We're like right outside Little Morrow.
Very, very deep.
I think I've gotten that.
I need more wood.
Oh, wait.
Shiny water?
And there's some shiny stuff over there too.
We'll grab that also.
Oh, my bad.
A host eel.
Ewww!
Numerous glowing shapes flicker and squirm behind a distended ribcage.
The rest of the fish is withered and drained.
Nasty!
Just a regular gray eel.
Ooh!
Trophy eel!
Let's go!
Alright, let's...
I'm gonna pack it up.
I'm just gonna...
I'm gonna go the long way.
Yippee!
Spooky music.
What is...
What the heck was that?
Oh, the dolphins.
Oh!
Oh, my god.
You were approached by a hooded figure.
Swarthed in dark blue robes, their face is barely visible.
Fisherman, please help.
You can barely hear their rasping whisper above the wind and waves.
Fulfill the hunger.
The hooded figure unfurls an old paper scroll.
They point to a shape shown at the top.
It appears to be a blue mackerel.
Oh, I didn't even see it there.
A blue mackerel, eh?
That shouldn't be so... hard.
There might be one right...
There!
There might be...
If you went two feet, you'd be able to get your own, buddy.
Oh, they're timed quests.
I see.
Luckily...
I can get him his fish immediately.
Guys, I don't know...
I guess we gotta really explore out...
Like, craziness.
Shiny.
I see it.
We'll get this guy first, though.
Fulfill the hunger.
With expert precision, they plunge their hands into the gullet of the fish and tear out the heart.
They stuff it into their mouth unceremoniously.
More still empty.
They point to another shape.
This one looks like a tiger mackerel.
Okay, well, I...
No!
No, it's gone!
Wait.
Rotten mast.
Look inside.
We got more doubloons.
We got this.
We got some scrap.
Very nice.
I think I should go home.
And put these in storage at least.
I need wood, though.
I need...
I need wood.
Yeah, we got another research part.
Let's go, baby.
Will I have to do this guy's quest all over again?
The mackerel, I know, but...
But...
I'm more afraid of losing my things.
More stuff to salvage by the fanatic.
Yeah.
Oh, it's not timed anymore.
Oh, a key can wait.
Oh, thank goodness.
Okay.
Thank you, guys.
Do I have room for this?
I don't think I do.
Let's go to this side first.
We'll sell our fish.
And then we'll sell our stuff on the other side.
Sell the fish.
90 bucks.
Not bad.
I'm just gonna put it in storage just in case.
Better to be safe than sorry, I suppose.
Especially with my driving.
I keep getting gross squids.
Yeah.
The guy survived somehow.
I guess, yeah.
Alright, we're at least making some money.
We do need that because we're going to want to buy more engine stuff anyway.
That was everything, right?
Seems to be so.
The painter.
Deliver a flag.
Let me see your flag.
You want to attach it?
Yes.
We want the Ouroboros.
As you wish.
Okay.
We need... We desperately need...
Some...
We desperately need some...
Is that wind or a giant seal?
Some wood.
Go away, spooky rocks.
I kind of want to just stay out all night.
I kind of want to stay out all night.
Materials are always close to shores.
Eventually.
If I...
How do I save my game?
Would I die?
If I died, what would I have to redo?
It saves every time you dock?
Oh, perfect.
And we just come back here.
Let's see if we go...
The fanatic was over here.
Oh my goodness, look at all this stuff going on.
Oh, this is where...
This must be where the lady said that she crashed her boat.
Why don't we try that?
That would be kind of interesting.
At night.
Oh wait, how do I turn my light back on?
There we go.
It was... Yeah.
Wait, right there?
Sorry.
No, I think it just...
Excuse you!
What's that light?
What is over there?
Oh, it must be the research outpost or something.
New BGM for it.
Is it this?
No.
I'm doing it guys.
I'm being brave.
And I'm staying out all night.
Wait, it's 5 AM.
The sun is rising.
We did it!
Oh, it's to the south.
We stayed out all night!
Oh, that's not good.
He is right behind me.
Why is the eyeball still up?
Am I still insane?
How much damage did it do?
I lost an engine!
Wait.
When did I get this guy?
The tornado gave me an offering?
He destroyed my ship and then also...
The collection of cases have washed up against the shore.
Some have already split open and lost their contents to the waves.
Look for valuables.
We got the photography equipment!
There might be some wood in here.
Please, please.
I'll still get it though.
Never hurts to have more money money.
A goblet.
It's fun.
How are you?
We stayed up all night.
Guys, oh my gosh.
How do you feel?
More like...
Where is all the wood?
Oh, shoot.
That was my fault.
Sorry.
One gold doubloon.
I feel bonita.
A curious looking chest is half submerged.
Use the spyglass to look for blood.
You're so right.
A lot of abyssal stuff.
Sad.
Oh, we're not crazy anymore.
I just noticed.
Let's go.
We got ourselves half a map.
Did I ever go to the research outpost?
I don't think I did.
I feel so...
That we haven't found any wood.
The wind is taking me.
Over there.
I see it.
I'm being pushed by the breeze.
Why does it feel like it turned to night so quickly?
Hello.
What we got here?
Some wood, hopefully.
Some boxes.
Look inside.
Thank goodness.
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
Okay.
We have to...
First of all, is this thing still fresh?
We gotta go sell stuff.
I'm gonna make a little mark on the map here.
A little place a marker.
Exclamation point.
Come back to wood.
And we're gonna go sell some things.
And do some stuff.
We also need to...
You can rotate.
I know, but...
We also gotta get that lady's stuff back.
Rotate your stuff.
You can take it all.
I'm scared of the night!
What if we lose it to a tornado?
Tornado!
I have half an engine, you guys.
I have to get my engine repaired, please.
That's why I'm so slow.
I only have half an engine.
What was that?
I'm so, so slow.
What's all that red over there?
Did I ignore?
I do not see.
I do not care.
Alright, repair.
Oh my god.
Why are there eyeballs everywhere?
Oh god.
I think I'm in trouble.
I think I need to sleep.
Anyway, fish market.
Yeah, we're gonna sell the fish.
I don't care.
I do not perceive.
Oh, wrong thing, sorry.
Should be hard.
Wait, it says disabled.
Can I not fix it?
Oh, okay.
Oh, my bad.
For some reason I was thinking that...
Don't worry about me.
I was thinking that the repair was on board, you know.
We have one research part.
I haven't unlocked nets yet.
Storage?
Yeah, you're right.
Store, store, store, store, store.
Sleep.
Wait.
Well, I'm gonna go take the camera stuff back.
My storage.
Take the camera.
I don't know if she has one there.
And we'll go sell all that stuff later.
Nobody saw that.
Nobody saw?
Okay.
There's something here.
I saw it sparkling earlier.
Stone hums quietly.
Sending ripples through the air around it.
Faint shapes dance upon its surface, vanishing before your eyes.
Before your eyes can focus on them.
The cold stone does not... Oh, a hint.
The cold stone hates us.
It's fine.
You saw?
No, you didn't.
You probably were sleep dreaming.
Wait, that's what you usually do when you sleep, huh?
You probably just were mistaken a little.
You were sleepwalking.
Okay, let's grab this.
The other part of the map.
Wood!
Oh, sweet wood.
We're gonna go over here.
Welcome to the membership.
Thank you.
There's gotta be some stuff in here, right?
Then we'll go to our photographer friend.
And I'm also gonna wanna go sell some of this stuff probably.
Nice.
Oh, bag of doubloons.
And wood right here.
This is gonna be wood.
It's scrap.
Do I have room for scrap?
I do.
Any supply is a good supply.
Alright, scrap.
Oh wait, there was more?
Oh, just more scrap.
We'll come back.
Lady is right over there, no?
I wanna get this camera stuff off my hands.
Panic!
Thank you so much for the 5 gifted.
Thank you.
Thanks for being my Kamiyoshi.
Thank you for choosing me as your Kamiyoshi.
Wait a second.
That's not a lady.
Lady?
Lady is down here.
Lady.
That's a lady symbol?
She's a green flag.
Um... I could see if there's any...
Oh wait, wait, wait.
Why aren't you... Why?
I know I'm like 2 feet away from it, but come on.
Scrap!
Wait!
Oh my god, we found the wood!
7P!
Thank you so much for the 10 gifted.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Okay.
Alright.
We're back in business, baby.
Let's go to this lady.
Wood, wood, wood, wood, wood, wood.
Wood, wood, wood, wood, wood, wood, wood, wood, wood, wood.
And it's not even just one piece of wood, it's multiple wood.
Oh, thank goodness.
What's that sound?
I think it's a whale.
Am I going... This is the lady, right?
I'm almost positive.
Oh no!
The mist!
The insane mist!
Ouch!
Lady?
Campsite?
I think I went to the wrong place.
Next to the dock is a derelict campsite.
Strange symbols are scratched into the sand.
Search the campsite.
Extremely rough and worn sheet of fabric is collapsed at the base of some wooden supports.
There's nothing remarkable about it.
The symbols in the sand?
The symbols span in breadth of the camps, twisting this way and that.
Some are grouped together in what must be words.
Fresh footprints tread carefully around each symbol.
The last symbol trails off hurriedly and looks unfinished.
Red.
I lost the lady.
Where's the lady?
Inspect the last symbol more...
The footprints.
Whoever left the footprints behind was barefoot.
The prints are large and wide.
Perhaps indicating they were left by a man.
You don't know much about footprints.
A glint of metal.
We got a sapphire ring.
I'll take it for myself.
I hope nobody attacks me.
Good night.
Guys, where the hell is this lady?
I think she's more this way.
All I hear are monkeys.
Oh my god, we were so close to her.
She was right there!
We were right next door.
Is my engine... I lost one, but that's okay.
Wrong address.
Who... who was that then?
Mysterious.
We'll have to explore that island a little bit more.
Going through a hard time.
Appreciate the streams.
I hope everything's okay.
You have the lenses.
Oh, I do hope they've not been damaged by the seawater.
She takes the case from you and inspects each lens carefully.
They seem mostly unharmed.
Nothing that some careful polishing can't remedy at least.
We got the camera.
Should allow you to capture some good shots.
If you wanted some advice on locating wildlife to photograph, just say the word.
Mammal.
Reptiles?
Glad you asked.
Not many consider reptiles when they think of the ocean.
Loggerhead turtles are a common sight.
Oh, like the dolphins and whales we've been seeing.
They can be hard to spot in the water.
When it comes to larger reptiles...
Crocodiles!
What do we get for taking pictures?
Okay, I can't research anything yet.
Let's...
The wood?
Yeah, I'm trying to figure out...
Um...
I don't have a ton of inventory for wood.
I would have to move some stuff around.
I could fit...
I could fit a couple pieces.
There we go.
Oh, storage!
Thank you.
Yeah, we'll store it.
We'll store stuff here.
Nevermind, I don't think she has storage.
She does not have storage.
Sucks.
Did the campsite have storage?
I don't think so.
We came from that camp.
Right there or over here?
Everything looks the same!
What is you?
Scrap.
Hello!
Hello, hello.
Skibity.
No skibity.
Oh no, no.
No, no, no.
No skibity.
What's that over there?
Is that anything?
It's another cloak guy.
Let's see what he's got to say.
He's yellow.
Hello!
An answer.
What is that thing?
Oh, red snapper.
Okay.
Is this a red snapper?
That would be great.
Hell yeah.
These guys are so stinking lazy.
You could just go two feet and you'll find what you need.
You're so hungry.
Use your words.
How long have you been waiting for someone to come deliver to you?
He's like, my Uber Eats always sinks.
Hey guys.
They rip through the throat of the fish and tear out its heart.
Oh, just like the other guy.
It's in their mouth before you have time to process what you just saw.
Uber Reels.
Could I get a nice cod?
Another.
A sacrifice.
Oh, I've never gotten this guy before.
I've got no abyssal.
Uh-oh.
A fangtooth.
I can't get that yet, mister.
You're gonna have to wait, okay?
Be patient.
Yeah, where's my tip?
Woah, a JW!
Oh my gosh, thank you so much for the 50 gifted.
Thank you!
It's starting to get dark.
I do need to do some repairs.
Where are we close to?
We're far.
We're kind of everything.
Oh, we can campsite right here.
I don't think it had a storage though.
Which sucks.
Nope.
I'm just gonna sleep.
I don't wanna risk it.
There's no biscuit.
Alright.
Back to... We'll go home.
Love this game.
Thanks for playing Minto.
Thank you!
Thanks for the superchat!
Thank you so much.
I know, I love this game too.
It's been two hours and it doesn't even feel like it for me.
I've just been... Actually...
That's kind of terrible now that I think about it.
It's been two hours and I've made like zero progress.
You guys heard that too, right?
Wait, what's this house right here?
Oh.
No, just kidding.
That's the spooky manor that has the guy wanting the artifacts in it.
Sorry, I didn't recognize it from behind.
That was the stomach of the rogue guys because their uber fleets got delayed again.
What?
No...
It's just, you know, the wrong season.
Everything, you know...
Alright, let's sell some stuff.
I just wanted to...
I wanted to make sure I didn't have any fish that rotted or anything.
I didn't forget about the wood.
I did not.
But first I want to...
Sell a few things.
Oh, trade right here.
Oh, 200 bucks.
Let's go.
We gotta sell and I want to...
I want to...
Repair.
So that we are at our full engine capacity, you know.
This is a mess in here.
This is just a straight up mess.
Let's organize a little bit.
Make it nicer.
Okay.
And this.
Our mysterious map.
That doesn't connect at all.
Not even a slight little anything.
Oh, just kidding.
It connects.
It does connect.
Yeah.
Wait, do we have a map that... Do we have anything on the map that looks like...
It looks like a dog.
Dog.
We need more evidence.
Alright, sold all my stuff.
Let's go repair.
Let's go get some wood and then... Oh my gosh, we can finally...
Once we... Once we repair... Wait.
The wood was...
Actually, let's get the wood first.
Dog.
There's wood in your little marrow?
Where?
Oh, there's something over there.
Something in the winds.
You see it?
Eel.
Not wood.
Wood?
Stingray?
Blue mackerel.
Was that...
It was maybe... I don't remember actually.
I should have placed a marker, huh?
I'm a fool.
Wood to the right.
Thank you so much for the 50 kits.
Thank you.
This is not wood.
You guys tricked me.
I've been deceived.
This is not wood.
I thought it was wood too though.
I thought it was wood too.
Not wood.
Suddenly it's 8 PM.
Suddenly we need to go home.
Son of a gun.
I tried to avoid it.
You have to do nothing all day.
I got two things of cloth and then it became night.
Our repairs are steep, but we must do what we must do.
I can still afford a third...
A third engine.
Shall we?
Uninstall.
Should I sell it?
The improved one?
How much is it usually?
It's usually 180.
I can sell it for...
Oh wait, I can sell this weak valve engine too.
This goes 15.
No, this goes 18.
You also need money for the whole upgrade.
Yeah, you're right.
Which was quite a bit actually.
It was quite a hefty sum.
We'll have enough for the engine slot.
I'm gonna... Wait, 270?
It's cheaper here.
Wasn't it 350 at the other places?
Guys, we got bamboozled.
Oh, I got the discounted book!
That's right.
That's so right.
Alright, dry dock.
Alright, one wood.
Two scrap.
And storage.
We'll do this for now.
Upgrade.
Alright, now we got two more engine spots.
Which we could also...
We could... Wait.
Oh shoot.
There's even like this.
Okay, hold on.
It's a cargo.
If I rotate it...
Oh my gosh!
Install.
Install it?
Why won't you install it?
Oh there it is.
Oh my gosh!
Oh, we're gonna be zooming for real now.
With the fish space.
We have to get that to get more space.
See, if you see here.
Under the... No, sorry, not the research.
The dry dock.
We'll get the new hole, but we have to get this to be able to get the new hole.
So we have to get this too.
Which we need more wood.
And the cloth.
Okay.
I just noticed that there.
Can I move any of these?
Okay.
I love seeing you and Nimi stream!
Thank you!
It's amazing that you've never collabed before.
I just like her.
A little bit.
I sold my fish, right?
Yeah, we got nothing.
How much money do I even have?
60 bucks.
Could be worse.
Alright, rest.
Sorry, we're farming stuff still.
That's okay.
That's how the game goes.
Speed!
Holy moly.
Isn't this like a big fish?
Nice!
We got a trophy fish.
Good luck there, honestly.
I know we're so fast.
Wood on the left?
Okay.
Of the island?
I was gonna go check out... I'm trying to find where that wood was before.
That we got.
Look how far we are and it's only 930.
This is great.
One moment, please.
Oh, we are so in desperate need of more storage.
Oh no!
The pain of big fish.
Drop the shark?
How much is it worth?
Shark on top, sword on bottom.
Sword does not fit on bottom.
Unless?
No.
Sword does not fit on bottom.
I can't move these, you guys.
These are permanent slots.
Upper left slot, upside down.
Shark in the upper left slot?
But this guy can't go down here.
He has to go up top.
I guess we gotta...
My trophy fish.
I literally just said lucky.
Vertical?
No, you won't fit.
This guy doesn't fit.
This is literally impossible.
It hurts.
We're scrub.
It has to be like right around here.
Because...
That's where that was.
We came from over that way and we thought it was like this island or something.
Wasn't there wood?
There was wood somewhere.
That's what we're searching for right now.
It was next to the ring.
Wait, no.
Where did we go?
I should have marked it.
Near the ship?
It wasn't!
I didn't see it on the thing.
I didn't see it on the telescope.
It was?
Let me see.
Oh wait.
There it is.
Thank you.
My eyes deceived me, but you guys led me to salvation.
I shouldn't have doubted.
I shouldn't have doubted you!
Oh wood, oh wood.
You're so beautiful.
And depleted.
So sad.
Time to go home and not lose any of this wood.
Please, please, please.
Let's make it home in one piece.
Can I get an item?
I'm scared of using this in like a... what's it called?
A rock appearing in front of me.
What's that?
Don't say hello.
There's two of them!
That's crazy.
There's two of them.
They're out patrolling.
You see that?
I should honk.
I've already honked.
I know what you're...
I'll do it again though.
I'm too fly.
He actually said hi.
Anyway.
I don't think those are real boats.
I need $125.
Time to make some money.
Oh wait, a dock?
And I'm gonna sell this bad boy.
Oh wait!
I have a fish!
What's wrong with me?
$345!
Sell a total of $2,500 worth of fish.
I have enough money.
We have four net spaces.
Alright, the hold is a lot of money.
And a lot of stuff.
Let's see.
We need three...
fabrics, two scraps, which we've got.
Lucky, lucky.
And we need two more wood.
And then the refined metal.
Alright.
And then obviously money.
Which I know she... Oh wait, there's the net.
Catches coastal.
Interesting.
Get a travel net, it's a game changer.
Wait, seriously?
This thing?
Or the trawl net?
Sorry, I saw travel.
Upgrade the net first.
Wait, but then I...
Like this?
Passively catches fish.
My hydraulic rod was for wood.
This is for oceanic fish.
So if I just like go out...
We're just gonna go vibe in the ocean.
It said coastal, right?
Yeah.
Oh.
Select the trawl net ability with E and lower it with...
I think I'm guessing I can just kind of go anywhere, but...
Fishing at 4 AM.
4 AM.
4 AM fishing.
This is when all the really good fishers are out and...
Fishing for stuff.
This is like the real fish time.
Real fish hours.
Are you kidding me?
Was this what someone was telling me about earlier that I just completely...
Completely ignored?
I apologize.
Well, it's depleted.
Oh, what did I get?
Maybe.
It's kind of slow.
Let's go search for some more wood maybe.
I'm gonna search around the island.
Since I guess that's what you're supposed... That's how you're supposed to play the game probably.
You know.
No oceanic...
Hmm...
What are you?
Wait, is this a stone?
And we touch it and it doesn't do anything?
Place your hand on the stone.
It does not respond to...
How do I become... How do I become worthy of the stones?
Spooky.
Oh, my bad.
Barbed Eagle.
Gross.
Troll net went up.
Yeah, I know.
I have to manually hold it which kind of sucks.
It's 1PM.
How do I collect the fish once I...
Once I have them?
I shouldn't have to hold it?
Oh, I thought I was holding it.
Just kidding.
It'll sell automatically.
Is this more... No, this is cloth.
But we still... This is still good.
I do this every time.
Nice.
Bolt of cloth.
What is that?
That also is something.
Maybe scrap?
We shall return.
Oh, our third fish.
I like passive fishing.
It also doesn't waste any more time.
So that's actually pretty huge.
Like you get fish for money and it doesn't...
It doesn't like add to you having to...
Spend your time fishing.
Wait, so if I go here...
Sold 4 fish.
Oh yeah, I see net.
I see, I see.
I see, I see, I see.
Alright.
We need the wood and we need the...
The thing.
How much money did I get from that?
Oh, 100 dollars I think it was.
Net profit.
Oh wait, we got another wood.
Add to the wood.
The new hole will be our main goal.
Plus 4 cargo spaces.
I need it.
Gosh, we really need to go scavenging, huh?
Like big time.
Alright.
Where was it that I...
Oh, over here.
There was more scrap and such.
Yeah, baby.
And we're so fast.
This is awesome.
Oh my gosh, game changer for real.
Now we're gaming.
Now we're playing the game.
Oh wait.
Old iron chain.
Ok.
What are you?
Oh, scrap.
We'll always need more of that.
We're out of scrap.
Little scrap.
More scrap please.
I feel so relaxed you guys.
Wait.
The
pleading.
Perfect.
Oh, this is a...
Diaper of the deep.
Ok.
Good stuff.
Did I have any treasures to sell?
Oh, we can go sell the iron thing.
Let's get it out of the way since we're here.
We're chilling in the coastal.
We're just being, you know.
Buy that please.
Thank you.
How much was that anyway?
5 bucks?
Where is another coastal area we can go exploring at?
I have a question also.
Do the fish in the net, do they...
Do they rot?
Oh, store the scrap.
You're so right.
Oh, I can store it here.
No?
That's huge!
Is it because they're all like chilling in there?
Scrap, scrap, scrap.
I'm gonna put this all down here.
Our little treasure map.
Unlimited power.
What else do we have in here?
We have no books unfortunately.
Catch a fangtooth.
Catch a tiger mackerel.
The conger eel.
Where was the conger eel at?
Gale cliffs.
Once we're faster...
Okay, once we're doing the...
Once we get the hole, I wanna try and do this one.
Because...
Yeah, we got chased away.
Yeah, yeah, there was that really big guy.
Okay, so once we're a little bit faster and stronger and everything...
I wanna... I want to attempt...
Is this... This looks like cloth.
Yeah.
Got one of the Metal Gear OST vinyls.
And my dad was super confused as to why I listened to a video game OST.
Turns out he still thought games had 8-bit noise soundtrack.
That's so cute!
Cute!
But it's funny because there are people that listen to 8-bit soundtracks, no?
Is this wood?
Scrap.
Oh my goodness, that was so close.
I started to zone out.
We can finagle another one.
We're getting so much supplies.
Why is it so hard to get wood here?
Are boats not made of wood anymore?
What's the issue?
Is that wood right there?
I spoke too soon.
And then once we get a lot of fishy...
We should probably get... So I'm gonna get the wood.
Then I'm gonna go... I'm gonna get some big fish.
Nice.
We're gonna get some big fish from, like, some big oceanic fish.
And we're gonna sell those.
And we're gonna make a big bunny.
Depleted.
Sad.
I wish this was Minecraft.
Right?
We could just get the wood from the trees.
The metal.
Yeah, we need the refined metal.
Which I know she sells.
I do know she sells it.
Like the traveling merchant lady.
But also...
Is this, like, oceanic?
Oh, I can't do oceanic anymore!
That's right!
I don't have my...
Okay, we're just gonna passive income, baby.
All the way.
Sometimes when you get older, getting wood isn't as easy as it used to be.
Is it because it's heavy?
I believe in you.
Oh, what?
What?
Is this a... Oh, black grouper.
She believe.
Why are you guys saying A-O?
What did I say?
What did I say this time?
I'm scared.
Is it because I said I believed?
Oh, there's so many big rocks.
So many rocks.
Don't worry about it.
Making a joke.
Funny joke.
168.
We're so close.
Two hours remaining.
Oh, until it needs repair, probably.
Okay, congratulations on your wood.
Thank you!
What are we talking about?
Oh my gosh, I got one so easy.
I'm just gonna fish in here, I'm not gonna lie.
We're just gonna farm for a bit in here.
We'll get as many coastal fish as we can get.
As many fish as we can get.
Wandering merchant.
We also need money to pay for...
I guess we could go.
Like, let's go to the gale area, right?
My net's broken.
Is it?
It didn't say so.
Will it say that it's broken?
My net's broken.
There it goes.
lol
What?
Oh, that's the deep stuff.
I can't get... I was like, what's the red?
The red shiny.
Anything shiny attracts me.
I wish I could get oceanic stuff again.
I gotta upgrade my stuff immediately.
Research to upgrade a net for it to last longer.
Yes.
Let's see how much this lady's selling the special metal for.
Oh, I forgot to put in the wood.
Shipyard.
She's selling it for $450.
That means we have to get at least like $1000 to be able to upgrade.
But we can repair.
Let's repair our net so we can at least make that back.
Yeah, back to the grind everybody.
Back to the grind.
I only have one research.
This is such a huge guy, no?
We don't even have the space for those things yet.
Let's see.
Oh wait, three days.
Oh no, that's not the net.
Sorry.
Two days!
Atomic!
Thank you.
Welcome to the membership.
Let's do the net then.
So it at least lasts us longer.
I feel like I'm picturing why it's long.
Mangrove and shallow.
Volcanic coastal.
Coastal shallow.
Why isn't there a one catch all, huh?
Get the pot.
I always forget to check them though.
Oops, not my storage.
Fish market.
Oh yeah, fish market.
These, the crab pots.
There is a DLC.
You can leave them by merchants and sell them right there.
But I don't want to do it here.
I don't know when we'll be back.
Let's check around here real quick.
Oh wait.
Lower.
There we go.
Does this count as coastal?
Oh it does.
So we are technically in coastal waters.
But this guy, if we try to get over here, this guy is going to eat our butts.
We know that for sure.
Some scrap.
And then this we need to blow up, no?
Or is this a stone that we touch?
Oh yeah, strong explosives.
Not my butt.
He will.
He'll get your butt.
What is this?
A resource bar.
I didn't even notice.
Crazy.
No damage though.
A freebie.
How did we miss that before?
I was working on this guy.
Is it worth even trying for the other engines?
Serious question.
No, not for a while.
Hearty crab pot.
Efficient crab pot.
A hearty would be better.
Oh wait, large crab pot.
Maybe a new net first.
We only have one research.
The last engine is better than the jets combined for the same space.
Yeah, it will take us a while though to get that.
Get the rod.
This one?
The flexible fishing rod.
But it...
Coastal shallow.
Oh wait, I can...
It's the same as this one.
Engines can be ignored until very late game.
Got it, got it, thank you.
I need my oceanic one.
Oh, the fishing speed is more.
The fishing speed is so much more.
I can't afford it though, unfortunately.
Hi Minto.
Hello!
Thanks for 11 months cryocyte.
You can use both rods?
You can!
I was thinking if I moved it over.
Sell the old ones.
True, you can sell this.
And...
We can sell this.
Our weighted line.
And this, our basic.
Now we can buy it.
Oceanic!
Oh yeah, I wasn't gonna sell.
I wasn't gonna sell this one.
But thank you.
Buy the metal first.
I'm thinking...
Even if we bought it.
I would have to save up so much more.
Which is worth more.
Organize a little bit.
I want all my nets together.
Or my engines together and my nets together.
Fishing is more immediate.
Yeah, exactly.
Full upgrade is huge.
That's true, that is true.
Most of the DLC complaints are just that they're short.
Which they are, but that doesn't mean they're not good.
The new gear is good.
I see, thank you for clarifying.
Alright, you guys convinced me.
You guys convinced me.
Not the research.
Oh, we can't even do it here.
Yes we can.
It's under...
Floating dock, there we go.
Now I need 500 bucks.
Better start fishing.
I know, I'll start fishing.
What are you saying short things?
What are we talking about, huh?
Alright, let's get to fishing.
The music is so cool.
I'm just gonna grab everything, you know.
I'm just gonna start fishing for everything.
We're right here, so we can just...
Fish, sleep.
Fish, this is the real fisherman life.
We fish, we sleep.
Oh, I got a flayed mackerel.
Wishing I was fishing.
You are right now with me.
We're fishing together.
Together.
Everything I do in game, I credit to us.
Holy mackerel.
We're fishing right now.
What is this?
Oh, this is this one.
Look at this tiny little guy.
Oh, he's a perch.
He's so small.
You know, I never went around the other side of this.
It's only one.
Let's go searching around this island a little bit.
Okay, it's already two.
Shiny rock?
Shiny rock.
What's that?
Oh.
Gold.
I need to get out of here.
It's starting to turn night.
Can I dock here?
I wish.
I think he left me alone.
Dang it, I wanted to get the gold.
What's the best way through?
Um...
You can dock.
Oh, I can!
Oh my gosh, it just showed up!
Oh my gosh!
A campsite.
You stand in the center of a campsite.
The fire's embers are cool, but ash is still steadily blowing out with the wind.
Check the tent.
The tent is a sheet of cloth suspended over some sticks.
There is nothing inside, save for a smooth hollow in the dirt where someone slept.
What do you want to do?
Footprints?
There's no footprints, but unfamiliar symbols have been sketched in the dust nearby.
Some have been erased with the hasty sweep of a foot.
Why is the music so ominous?
Campfire.
Large flat rock sits atop the charred wood of the campfire.
A handful of tiny fish bones can be seen poking out of the ashes.
Kick the ashes!
Huge!
Okay, I like that.
I'm thinking this one.
I'm more in coastal and shallow at the moment than I am in mangrove and volcanic, no?
If you sleep, you lose the cargo ship.
What?
Wait, what do you mean?
Yeah?
The fish will rot.
Oh wait, my cargo fish.
Oh, you're right!
You're right, you're right.
Okay, you're right, you're right.
They rot.
I forgot that I actually fished.
I forgot that I fished.
Okay, we'll just turn around and we'll go back.
I think I might save up for this thing though.
I think passive income is a good thing.
Alright.
Let's go.
Just go fast!
The fastest boat that ever could!
I don't know how to get inside here.
Is there like a little inlet somewhere?
I see it on the map but I don't know where it is and it's too foggy for me to see anything.
Hug the coast.
We made it!
Well, don't count the chickens.
I sell all my stuff.
138 dollars.
What did we get in here?
That thing is horrible.
Eyeless and mindless.
Driven only by a desire to consume.
A purpose satiated many times over.
Holy teeth.
Rend in flesh and muscle and bone exposed.
This gory mess of a fish can't have lived like this for long.
Anyway.
Holy cow.
Consume!
Only sells for 18 bucks.
Gosh, if only we could get...
What was it?
That big...
The big messed up fish.
The big mutated fish.
It was a swordfish, no?
I think.
That I caught earlier.
He was crazy.
Let's check around this area now.
What are you?
Oh, I can't get it.
Dang it.
Is this technically oceanic?
Huge!
Nice.
Huge for me at least.
Always need more wood.
Depleted.
Huge wood.
No!
That's some scrub.
Wait.
I was going to get my camera.
Is this like a...
Yeah.
What we got here?
I want to take a picture!
That looks expensive.
No!
Don't come back!
Come back!
We'll get them next time boys.
For now, I'm going to circle.
I wish I could catch that giant fish that chases after us.
I could zoom past him.
And like, just attempt to do, you know...
Trying to get more fish by the way.
What's that sound?
I think it's a...
Yeah.
We need a bigger boat.
Soon.
We're so close.
I just got to sell like 5 more fish.
500 more fish.
We're so close.
Dang, my storage is filling up.
If we go to the floating dock...
I wish I could start putting stuff in these, you know.
But not quite yet.
Not quite yet.
Indeed.
Oh, I got to buy the improved one though.
How much was this?
225!
I got to buy the new net.
10 per day.
8 per day.
Oh...
Troll nets break down real fast.
Yeah, they do.
I think though...
Wait, how much was it?
270.
I think though it's still better for me to save up for the big boat.
Not gonna lie.
Repair before selling.
You'll save money that way.
I was wondering if selling it when it's repaired would bring up its value.
I'm gonna go back around like I did before.
I like the music so much.
It's so like...
Sometimes it feels very like...
What's it called?
Like this feels like the soundtrack of like an Indiana Jones film.
Wait, I don't want to dredge right now.
I don't want to fish right now.
Sets the mood.
It does.
So cool.
You think that guy is gonna come after me?
What is this?
A pirate flag!
I like that.
He's somewhere in there.
A pirate flag!
Let's go.
Can't tell if this is oceanic fish or not.
Right now we'll just get some...
Okay.
Oh wait, that one doesn't sell for very much I remember.
That's okay though.
I'm collecting stuff to sell.
We could always go back to...oh this is paper.
Afternoon Minky just got back from Japan.
This is some scrap.
There's a lot of supplies around here.
Going in here, I might get attacked by the guy.
There's something shining.
What was the...oh they wanted that eel.
They wanted me to find the eel in here.
What the hell is that?
Which I know resides inside...in here.
The conger eel.
Oh they're night fishes.
Is that what they were?
They're night fishes.
Yeah, they want them rotten.
Which we can do.
I'm scared.
I'm scared to get it.
Especially with that big ol' fish riding around.
Could I catch him in the net?
Or no, it's not possible.
Almost a year of mint.
Thank you Rodrigo!
I can't.
Do it when you upgrade.
Oh maybe.
So true.
Oh my gosh.
Wow.
Okay, that was targeted for sure.
Research part.
Nice.
Go home.
Rodrigo, thank you for the 20.
Gifted.
Is that where I deposit some fish?
Thank you so much Rodrigo.
I'm scared.
Oh my gosh.
I'm kinda far.
Just kidding.
No!
Alright, we're gonna try and get some eel.
We're gonna try and get some eel.
Sell all fish.
We've made nothing.
Good.
Alright.
Someone said I don't have to go actually inside.
But I could.
Is it?
I wonder though if it's like a... I guess it wouldn't be an oceanic.
Eel cliffs.
This guy maybe?
Wait.
It's coastal.
Eel cliffs.
I'm guessing it must be that one.
It's shallow.
Okay, shallow.
Look around the island, not inside.
Okay.
I think we can be able to do it.
Can he fit?
Wait, that's an even bigger question.
What?
He needs...
4x4.
I feel like he can... Oh, my neck can't do it because he's shallow.
That's right.
Wait, I said 4x4?
2x4.
Oh my goodness.
I was about to say he's thick.
Damn.
No one will fit in there.
Okay, he'll definitely fit.
Okay, let's go try and find one.
Hey, go away.
Shallow land.
Is this shallow?
Coastal.
What would be?
What's that over there?
Is that a house?
Was that always there?
Shallow.
Telescope really helps.
Go away.
I'm running into stuff.
Over here!
That is a huge rock.
Oh my gosh.
And he's prized!
I got a prize eel!
Okay, can I catch another one?
I don't think so.
Oh wait.
Oops, my bad.
Just in case I mess up.
Alright.
Thank you for whoever told me that I don't have to...wait.
That I don't have to go inside.
You saved my butt.
I was too afraid to do it.
No, don't do that.
Please.
Don't do that.
You're scaring me.
My sanity is going insane right now.
If I go too insane will I die?
Go to sleep.
I took the quickest nap ever.
But now are my eels rotten.
No.
I could sell this one.
She doesn't care if it's prized or not.
It's not that much of a...
Sell the good one?
Yeah.
I misread the command.
I misread the sell one versus...
Sell all, you know.
For speed running.
Anyway.
OK, night time.
One more time.
How much money?
Oh.
We made...it was like a hundred something.
So not bad.
Eel hole!
I'm gonna get another one just in case.
Yeah, let's go.
Let's go home.
Not the best.
No!
Stay away!
Not the typhoon!
Or tornado!
OK.
Now, maybe if I sleep...
OK, so we are gonna sell this creepy one.
We'll sell the creepy guy.
A hundred dollars!
Nice.
See?
We are still farming, guys.
OK.
How do I sell the one?
Because this is where...OK, see?
It says sell for a hundred and eight.
I press F, but down here it says sell all fish for F.
Click and drag.
Now if I...tap F.
I see.
Thank you.
Holy moly.
Scary.
This guy is still fresh.
Disgusting.
We don't want it.
I want to put on my pirate flag so bad.
How long do you think it will take before it's rotten?
Rotten to the core.
What?
Missing.
Oh, do I need to repair it?
Just kidding.
Yeah, it's broken.
We shall...
Repair.
And then, if I sell it...
It's a hundred and thirty-seven dollars.
Nice.
And then we can get...
Oh no, I wasn't going to get the big bad.
What I think I'm going to do...
Hear me out.
I'm going to sell it.
And then...
I'm going to put my coastal rod back on.
Because now...
Even though...
I can't...
Use it...
I can...
Get the better boat.
Floating dock.
Here we go!
I'm really sleepy, but I conscripted into the family hell divers game.
Oh.
Yeah!
Thank you for being my chill left ear fishing while the gun fights on the right.
Oh gosh, how can you concentrate?
Boat goes bintin, mint goes mintin.
Super E, welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Okay.
Alright.
Now we can upgrade.
I can actually get this one.
Rod space, cargo space.
I could get this one immediately.
I'm going to start just putting stuff in though.
Because we have so much stuff in storage.
At this point, I have so much stuff in storage.
Materials here will be saved.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
More spaces, more money.
So true.
That's why it's so expensive to get it.
To get that upgrade.
Oh my gosh, look at that.
Wow, we have just enough.
Incredible!
Nice.
Enough for all the upgrades.
I just need the money.
And then, of course, obviously, the tier 3 hole.
Damn, we're gaming!
Finally!
For research.
I have the one part.
That's right, I was trying to get this large trough.
Which I think I will add to.
Is the eel still fresh?
Oh my gosh, stop it.
Why do I keep doing that?
My eel is...
Stale.
He's stale.
That's great.
Look at that, he looks so cute.
I love the mutant version of him.
He's so cute.
Can you wink for me?
I need a new PFP.
What do you mean?
Is Nemi profile picture not good?
When it's over land, it's a tornado.
When it's over water, it's a water spout.
Sorry for being well actually about it.
You are so right, PH, though.
Like that?
Or...
Wait, hold on.
I can't wink my other eye very well.
I can only wink this one well.
Like that?
Or...
Wait.
It doesn't work.
Do angry wink.
There you go.
That should be enough, right?
This should be enough food for you.
More.
You guys are so greedy.
Cute.
Stop it.
What's wrong with being greedy?
Maybe it's okay for greedy sometimes.
What else have we not caught in the gale?
This guy is shallow.
We haven't caught him yet.
The oceanic guys.
What is this?
The shallow.
Let's go back to that shallow area.
Undock.
Where we got the eel.
And we can maybe get some other guys too.
What are you talking about?
Oh, the crabs.
Crab, crab, crab, crab.
Is this oceanic?
Coastal.
That's a little perch.
Here's some wood.
I'll come back for later.
Wow, I'm not like foaming at the mouth for wood anymore.
I've grown.
Oh, wow, there's no eels here.
Oops, I forgot my trawl.
That's okay though.
What are you?
Blackmouth seagull.
You are a messed up little fish.
That's what you are.
You're a disturbing little creature.
That's me talking to Ocelot.
Yeah, you're just a screwed up little guy.
Decaying blackmouth.
Shimmering blackness permeates the flesh of this relentless fish.
Muscles atrophied and decaying, but still it swims on.
Oh my gosh, have you guys... That's like a real thing though.
Have you guys ever seen the fish that are like...
The zombie fish?
The zombie salmon?
They're so icky.
How's the eel?
I think he is stale still.
What's it blowing towards?
The wind is so mysterious.
I love it.
How long until it's rotten?
I guess I could sleep again maybe.
God, I just looked it up.
That is wild.
It's creepy, right?
Such fine stuff.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
I'm never doing fine stuff ever again.
Oh, a black sea bass landed on deck.
Dang it.
This is... This is why.
Good drift though.
Thanks.
Captain Ma is on the scene.
It's still stale.
Sell, sell, sell.
And then we'll repair.
Oh, wrong thing.
Sorry, my bad.
Repair.
Been enjoying my deliveries in Death Stranding to prep for two while watching you dread.
Yeah, in a couple weeks I plan on doing a Death Stranding week.
That water spout timed it on purpose.
Not that spout.
Yeah, it's not mean as the spout.
So true.
Oh wait, let's sleep actually.
Let's sleep actually and so then I can...
Because I also want to get ready for Death Stranding too.
Have you ever played through Policenauts?
I have not.
But yes, I've been... Running!
Guys, let's go complete a quest!
I will play Policenauts though.
Just a matter of... Of when.
Lady?
Where's the lady?
Oh, here she is.
Ingfell resident.
Here's your aged Conguriel.
Perfect, this will do wonderfully.
I can offer you a small sum in thanks.
Safe travels.
Thank you!
I got 150 bucks.
Let's go!
Actually, I have to go to the little ghost's room.
Is that okay?
I will go...
How long have I been streaming for?
Three hours!
Yeah, okay.
I'm gonna get some more tea as well.
So, just a short little break.
I'm literally gone fishing.
Go ghost, go.
I will take us with you!
I mean... Okay, I'm gonna take the mic with me.
Okay, I'll be right back.
I'm back!
Oh my gosh, pollen is making my throat all itchy.
You guys also have...
Do you guys also have allergies recently?
Welcome back.
Tadaima!
Yeah.
Somehow I've been spared from it this year.
I've been like opening the windows a lot in the maid cafe, so...
It's like extra bad, but it just feels so nice.
It feels so nice.
Lofton.
What's that?
There's still snow on the ground up there.
Wow.
Okay.
Note of entry.
That's opening the windows to let the ghosts out.
But like... But like other ghosts.
You wouldn't let me out when I'm in your home.
That's like the lame ghost.
The ghost... Those ghosts suck.
Yeah, I agree.
You want to get those ghosts out, but Minto you want...
You want Minto to stay, right?
Windows taped shut.
I'm trapped.
No windows in the basement.
I'm definitely not getting out.
Yes.
You can't leave.
Okay.
Okay, you said it, not me.
Alright, good job guys.
We just did...
another...
quest, finally.
If you could go out the window if you want, you're welcome to stay.
I'm staying.
I mean, well, I mean...
Only because you were so begging me to stay here.
Minky!
Catch a tiger mackerel.
Where do I find the tiger mackerel?
Have I gotten that before already?
Marrows, tiger.
We got the blue mackerel.
Tiger, tiger.
Oh, tiger mackerel.
At the gale cliffs.
I caught six?
When?
But they're coastal.
It's like still morning even, so this is perfect time...
to catch and to deliver.
Minto, a super cool smile.
Thanks, Dekofit.
Thanks for 11 months.
I can't believe it.
11 months.
Alright, that guy was weird.
Where was that guy?
And a fang tooth.
On the island between the Marrows and Gale Cliffs.
So like here maybe?
Around this area?
Or here?
Catbuzz, thanks for 11 months.
I can't either.
Feels like you just came back.
I know, me too.
Might be even cuter when you're clink.
I'm leaving.
I'm taking my boat.
I'm taking my boat!
Wait, I didn't even notice...
How much more storage we've got.
Was he in here?
I think maybe in here.
There she blows.
I forgot.
He happened so fast I couldn't get my camera out.
There he is.
Sad and small.
Hungry.
Hello mister.
I got your tiger.
He's like literally bones.
More still empty tiger mackerel.
They rip it.
Again, they rip into the flesh of the fish, drawing out its heart.
It's consumed as quickly as the first.
Almost fulfilled.
They point to a fish on the final scroll.
A snake mackerel.
We know.
We've caught that one before.
Where?
Snake mackerel.
Snake macaroni.
Devil's spine.
Oh Andrew!
Thanks for the breed!
Thank you, thank you.
Alright.
Devil's spine.
That's pretty far from here, buddy.
You're asking a lot.
Actually, it's like right there.
You can see it on the map.
Well, I guess that's like kind of the area.
Just in case I forget.
Cute twintail minky!
I guess should we go?
I think we'll make it.
Or we'll have to stop by... Oh my gosh, this is big money so we definitely need to get this.
Wait!
Hooked sailfish.
Wait, we haven't caught this before.
Spindles of bone protrude from discolored muscle.
A hooked bill curves inward.
A lure for something greater.
Maybe then I should go home.
And drop off our...
Okay.
Change of plans.
We go home.
We sell some of our stuff.
Because I also have some treasures to sell.
And we sell this guy.
Because he'll give us big money.
And we need the big money.
I love the OST in this game.
So good.
Wood.
Where were you?
Mint on the telly!
Chocomint ice in my hand.
Tis a nice Sunday.
It's such a chill Sunday.
At least for me.
I hope it's chill for you guys too.
Sell the ring.
Actually, sell... Oh, that was the only trinket I had?
Wait, what about this chain?
Can I not sell this?
Does it not... Do we need this?
Did you see the new rideable gas in Minecraft?
I did!
Yeah, I talked about it earlier.
Oh, there's no sell all in storage.
Ah, I see, I see.
Thank you.
And we give this guy our flag.
You want to attach it?
Yes.
Alright!
Happy...
Happy pirate!
There's a... I buy the X and Gale Cliffs if you want to continue the main quest.
There's a main quest.
Fighting Gojisai.
Thank you for the 5 gifted.
Thank you!
Okay, we have to go to Gale Winds anyway, so...
What were the winds pointing to?
Mysterious.
Big money!
Money!
Holy money!
Which one should we do?
We actually... Wait, how much money do I have?
I have 700 dollars!
Wait, I might be able to do everything.
You guys, I can do all of them.
But do I want to buy more little engines?
Oh, and this makes my rods bigger.
My one thing about the rods though is that I...
Even if I upgrade, I don't have any better ones, you know what I mean?
Oh yeah, also, I want to... Oh, I didn't buy this one.
I only have... Oh my gosh, it's still 414 dollars.
Use two?
Painter can paint your shipment with rarecrafts.
Yeah, I do remember that!
I do remember that.
If I have more rod space, I might be able to use this and this.
Did we pay off our debt yet?
Oh yeah, like a long time ago.
The time... Oh, it's not... People said it's not a timed quest.
Or rather, I think it used to be a timed quest?
No, it's not a timed quest, no.
Because we spent a lot of time.
Yeah, it's not timed anymore.
The devs changed it.
Apparently the devs changed it, but thank you for worrying about it.
Oh, it was minted?
Wait, okay, so if I get the... If I get the rod space upgrade...
I would be able to use the net as well.
Okay, let's get this.
We are mathematizing.
Wait, how do I remove this?
Oh, uninstall.
Look at this.
And then, the net.
It's still only coastal.
Hold on.
I still need one more research point.
I think I'll still get it though.
Still great passive income.
I think I'll still get it and it's good for two days.
Oh, I wouldn't even be able to hold the bigger one anyway because this is only for net or for rod.
I can't buy anymore engine for now.
I think that's what I might do next is fill up the engine.
It'll pay for itself.
True.
Alright, we sleep.
We undock.
We...
Set our trawl net out.
And we head over to...
The devil's spawn.
Good morning, Mito.
Oh, wait.
Oh my gosh, I forgot to...
Does this thing still have any fish in it?
The crab in here are...
I'll come back for it.
Okay.
Now this is dredging.
I probably could have some more crab traps out...
Around the world.
I haven't even gone to the twisted strand yet.
I haven't even been there.
I'm guessing the light blue is the coastal water so I'm going to kind of...
Stay in there for a bit.
Swordfish to your left.
Should I get it?
I did see it.
It's okay.
I'm already past.
What did I need to get here?
Oh, oh, oh...
Wait, he might come back.
Is that him right there?
Wheel!
It's a wheel!
Oh, I can really zoom.
What kind of technology does this lady have?
Wheel!
I took a picture of the whale.
Holy moly.
That guy is humongous.
It's a tiger mackerel.
And he is...
Oh wow!
There's different versions of...
I see.
Because I was like, I thought I got the mutated sailfish before.
Interesting, interesting.
Snake mackerel.
He's a coastal man.
Is this coastal?
Is this a snake mackerel?
No way.
Hell yeah it is.
What was...
Wait, there was a guy somewhere where?
Mint, tell us a funny joke.
Oh, sorry.
My fishing skills?
Alex, thanks for 11 bucks.
Thank you.
There was a guy, no?
Where is he though, the other guy?
By the fanatic, but not fanatic.
What was that?
I heard a bad sound.
Oh, not a bad sound.
Just Orca.
Did you watch the latest episode of Solo Leveling?
I have not watched Solo Leveling.
I have not watched it.
I'm scared to travel in here because of the mom.
And the little baby fish.
They're hungry.
Hungry fish.
I see that over there though.
I wanna grab it.
Let's go.
Wait, I'm gonna save at the dock?
It's also getting late.
But I'm gonna save at the dock.
Oh wait, all my fish are gonna die.
He can eat stale fish.
Most likely.
And I have these guys in here.
They'll stay fresh.
These guys, the net fish will be fine.
Or should I just go deliver it to him?
And come back?
I can't decide.
It's so red.
Oh my gosh, I can't see anything.
Can you move from storage to net?
Let's see.
No, it doesn't look like it.
I'll come back.
I'm just gonna sleep.
It's fine.
Wooly gooly, thank you for your 11 bombs.
A memorable man!
Oh my goodness, thank you so much for the 15 candidates!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Alright, undock.
Let's see.
They're just stale.
What is that?
Oh, it's a message in a bottle.
What is that sound?
It's scaring me.
Okay, let's go back to our freaky fellow.
What is that sound?
I don't like it.
Big mama?
Nice!
I don't know if I'm going the right way.
I am definitely not.
I need to go south.
You turn!
I'll think about doing the DLCs.
We'll see how much I do of this game though.
Rather, how long it takes me.
YouTube is...
Wait, YouTube is meeting the fishing community today.
Wait, what's that?
What are you talking about?
Okay.
And he is...
Like, right here, no?
Right here.
Okay.
Our little guy.
The logo of YouTube today is a fish in a rod?
Is it this way?
Sometimes it's confusing when you're looking at the map upside down.
And they are rotting.
He'll probably still eat it.
I believe.
I believe he'll eat it still.
The rotting fish, you know?
We're almost there!
Oh, there he is!
I almost passed you, buddy.
Gosh, why are you so small?
He's like the tiniest person ever.
Every fish is ginormous compared to you.
Oh, see, it worked!
Berry bug.
Where are you?
Oh, berry ray?
What?
Berry bug ray?
Paperbacks, thanks for the five gift card!
Berry!
Why does she say bug like that?
What's wrong with the way I say bug?
Mervy, thanks for the five gift card.
Wait, did a notification show up?
I just didn't see it.
Thanks for the red berry.
Thanks, girl.
Thanks.
It did?
Oh, sorry.
I'm so invested in this game.
Berry, you should play this game.
Oh my god, it's so much fun.
It's so fun.
Thanks for the five gift card!
Their head tilts upward to look at you.
They take a book from inside their robe and hand it over.
Hunger sated.
Now I wait.
They cross their arms and appear to fall into a deep sleep.
Oh my god, he's educated.
Wow.
Haggling and bartering!
Hell yeah.
Let's see this.
June 1st, 1927.
Yesterday was the reading of his mother's will.
Most of the remaining estate went directly to him, of course.
But to my surprise, she bequeathed me her pocket watch.
Curious.
I'm not fond of the thing.
But I know that taking it will mean a lot to him.
I cannot help but feel it is some veiled jab at me from beyond the grave.
She was the type to do such a thing.
Was I late on some occasion?
I cannot recall.
This guy is British.
There's a co-op mod?
Oh my god.
That would be crazy.
I would lead her to every sanity draining mist ever.
Pocket watch?
I don't think we got a pocket watch.
Wait, did we get a pocket watch and sell it?
I don't remember.
Look at all these fish we got.
We can go sell everything.
Okay, bye mister!
The other guy... I can't remember what he wanted.
It was...
We'll figure it out.
Irish pocket watch.
That doesn't really work as well as the wrist watch.
And that's 10.
I think this thing said it could hold up to 10 or catch up to 10 a day or something.
Fish.
Sell all fish.
That's it.
205.
You stingy.
Are you holding out on me mister?
I could get the engine space.
We're saving up, right?
We're going to save up for... Wait, actually I think I can afford it now.
Barely.
Let's go.
Now we're zooming.
I had repairs?
On what?
Wait, repair all to what?
What's broken?
Is my net broken?
Oh my net.
What?
Shall we go back to...
Wait, remove.
Should we go back to...
The devil's spine and try... Oh, the X marks.
Is that what you guys were talking about?
Let's go to the X marks on the spine.
X marks the spot.
That's what they say and I'm a pirate now.
I'm zooming now.
Don't forget the guy in Gale Cliffs.
They'll just give me a book too though, right?
Probably.
The winds.
The colorful winds.
If evil, why pretty?
Books are cool.
I gotta finish this one first.
I'm invested.
He gives explosives?
Don't say that.
Wait, the guy in Gale Cliffs is part of the main quest.
What guy in Gale Cliffs?
Wait, did you not say devil's spine?
The one
he didn't talk to.
I thought the red X was where I needed the explosives and I can't get in there.
The whaler guy in Gale Cliffs.
No,
there's a dock there.
I'm halfway there, you guys.
I'm halfway to devil's spine.
But we do need the explosives.
We actually do need those.
Utah!
We do actually need that.
What are these guys?
Oh, I need this thing.
Whatever that is.
Aw, shucks.
Last location for the main quest.
I was just going on my own journey.
I'm speedrunning the game.
I was speedrunning the game, apparently.
Trying to, at least.
What?
I've been trying to find a way to get explosives this entire time.
No way.
Will I lose all the fish if my net breaks before I sell them?
Alrighty.
This dock right here...
Oh my gosh.
Are you kidding me?
The guy that I needed to talk to was literally right next to the thing that I needed...
Sometime.
Truth be told, I've been reconsidering my position lately.
I have been happy here for so long.
My wife and I had such a beautiful life.
Until the collapse.
Now I'm alone.
I'm cut off by land and sea.
Left only with these trembling rocks on all sides.
Oh, I can help you move!
Oh, this groans.
Ehhh...
It's not that simple.
My brother would never.
You see, I used to live in Ingfeld with my brother.
He was a whaler back in the day.
Things were bad.
We fought a lot.
Mostly about how our parents' inheritance should be divided.
We were in the prime foolishness of our youth.
When my wife and I decided to move here, I took the family crest.
I stole it from him!
Now after all this time, I can't return without it.
Ah, where is it?
That's where the problem lies.
After the collapse, that creature, it dragged debris from the houses down into the wretched burrows.
The crest went down with it.
Oop!
Sounds like a you problem.
It's a lost cause.
But if you were to find it, it's a large whale bone crest.
It would mean the world to me.
Ah, don't get your hopes up, Gramps.
Oh, ah, woah.
Hermit!
Does he not have a name?
Ah, do you know where I could clear...
Wait, is that one that I saw in the middle of the little area?
Already saw it?
Is that the thing that we saw, probably?
Do you know how I could clear the debris around here?
You'd probably need some explosives to shift those rocks.
My brother at Inkfell used to make explosives.
For the whaling operations, you see.
Nasty stuff.
But with the whales all gone, I can't imagine he's still in business.
What else do you want to know?
Any shipwrecks around here?
So he probably gives us the...
Probably gives us the explosives once we...
Have our brothers make up.
Not make out, you guys.
God.
Clear the earwax out of your ears.
Someone that used to live here kept the shop...
No, the ship moored at the base of the cliff.
Until it was struck by some falling rocks and sunk to the bottom.
They were devastated at the loss.
We all were.
But it was a beautiful boat.
Decorated with all manner of memorabilia from their travels.
At low tide, I can still see what's left of the mast head poking through the waves.
What else do you want to know?
What's happening to these cliffs?
They're being consumed from the core by that hateful serpent.
Have you seen it?
That thing?
Nobody believed me.
Not until he started devouring our foundations.
He eats rocks?
He's just a...
A fish that eats rocks?
Opening up chasms beneath our homes.
Rock and stared.
It was nightmarish.
Waking up in the night to the sound of a creature slithering somewhere underneath.
It seems to have turned its attention elsewhere.
But not before it took everything from me.
Tell me more about the creature that lives in the cliffs.
It's been burrowing tunnels through the base of the cliffs.
You can see the gigantic holes it leaves just below the surface.
As it forces its way out, it often causes rock falls.
So if you plan on going in there, keep an ear out.
Should it catch sight of you, well, you should be able to outrun it.
It's quite... it's not slow!
Provided you can navigate the passageways.
Slow where?
Now I have haste?
It's true.
I do have... I do have better speed now.
We're stronger than we were before.
If I go talk to the brother...
Can I go talk to a brother?
Will he give me more?
Will he give me explosives?
Oh, that's wrong.
Hello, retired whaler.
I heard you make explosives.
Aye, I did.
Sometimes the carcasses needed breaking up.
It wasn't the most efficient or the most pleasant, but it got the job done.
I've been thinking about getting back into it.
I might be able to rustle up something strong enough to clear those debris piles in the cliffs.
Ah, but I'm not sure.
I don't have the energy these days.
I'd have a use for explosives like that.
I'll think on it some more, but I make no promises.
Fickle old man.
Alright.
I'm just gonna go this way.
Since I've already committed.
We're gonna go get some stuff.
We're gonna go inside.
Probably.
And...
We're gonna get the crest, probably.
Brave Minky.
I'm not the...
I think...
Is that the guy coming after me?
That's 100% the guy coming after me.
If I go in here, I don't know if there's a way out.
But we're just gonna try.
Wait, do I have to dredge this?
Oh shoot.
And he's like right here, isn't he?
No he's not.
Maybe we're fine.
Evil game.
In and out.
I thought he was gonna chase me in there.
Oh thank goodness he didn't.
The ocean tribe is like...
Not so fast.
Nice.
What did we get?
We got...
5% increased sell prices and 5% reduced buy prices.
That's big.
Especially because we're about to sell stuff.
That thing was not slow at all though.
Excuse me?
The old man is insane.
151 fish in our net.
Not bad.
I only have 168 dollars though.
Not good.
And I'm going to...
I'm going to repair...
Our thing.
Yeah, we'll fix the net.
I got it guys, I got it.
Don't worry.
I'm fixing it, I'm fixing it.
More wood.
One scrap.
Three cloth.
And two fancy metals.
800 dollars.
Expensive.
Alright, let's go to Gramps.
Grandpa!
Hello again, what can I do for you?
Is this your family crest?
You found it!
I never thought I'd see this beauty again.
And I found it in like two seconds, Grandpa.
Now I have a further favor to ask.
Would you take this to my brother at Ingfeld?
Tell him...
Tell him his brother is sorry and would like to come home.
Okay.
Turn around.
Wait.
That thing was there.
I saw a shiny.
I see a shiny!
Should I go get it?
Let's aim for shiny.
Stonefish.
What the?
More stonefish.
Where's our creepy guy?
Oh!
Enthralled stonefish.
Nasty.
Okay.
I'm talking.
There's your creepy guy.
What is it?
I believe this crest is yours.
Gods, I haven't seen this since...
So he did take it.
I knew it.
Your brother is sorry.
Will you let him come home?
I don't know.
I was in a right state when he left.
Okay, fine.
He can stay in my old workshop.
At least for the time being.
But I'll need some time to clear it out.
While I'm doing that, perhaps you can do something for me.
See, I've been trying to clear some debris in the pathways through the cliffs to make a shortcut.
With explosives.
I was able to set a charge, but the cliffs seemed particularly unsteady that day.
So I didn't risk detonating it.
You just need to get there and set it off.
It's not far in.
I left some yellow flags nearby.
You can't miss it.
Okay.
Woohoo!
Explosives!
Uh oh.
Freaky fog.
This is gonna make me freaky.
Oh god.
I think we need to sleep.
For real.
I think I need to go to sleep.
Would you like to buy this enthralled stonefish?
Good morning, Minto.
We are completely sane in the mind and body.
Yellow flags?
See, like there's this.
But I don't see any yellow flags.
Okay.
Yellow flags.
Oh, it's like inside.
Like in there?
Mister, are you crazy?
Trying to get me killed, mister?
I hear him.
While loose debris...
He was like...
He just...
Oh man.
He came and bit me and left.
Just a little love bite.
Oh la la.
The winds speak of something mysterious.
Where?
What?
The wood.
Is it the wood you seek?
No, it's beyond the wood.
Alright, let's go talk.
Let's go tell grandpa.
Everything's fine.
Oh.
September 9th.
Wait, I wonder if this is a continuation of the other one.
Because we had what?
Oh, come on.
We had September...
Another September one.
In fact.
He still refuses to take me aboard when he is working.
He is convinced that I will find it dull, or that the crew will be crass or otherwise intolerable.
Perhaps I'm being overly needy.
I know he needs time alone, but I am so desperately bored at home when he is away.
He recently installed some salvaging equipment onto the boat.
I think the idea of pulling up treasure is terribly exciting.
I must convince him to let me have a go.
Let our lady fish.
She yearns for the net.
You've done it.
We heard the blast from here.
Gods, the echo.
I'm surprised the cliffs didn't come down on your head.
I've got things ready here.
Go and tell my brother that he can come home.
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
So I undock, I dock.
Do you guys know how much time it takes to dock a boat?
Playing a game two times in one week?
What are you, doki?
Wait until I play the same game over and over again.
Your brother forgives you.
He found you a place to stay.
He does?
That's a huge weight off my chest.
When so old, I hardly remembered it was there.
Right, well I'm packed and ready to go.
I can't get over the fact that we put these people in our cargo.
Alright, mister.
This way.
This won't end badly.
It's fine.
Well here we are.
What if he gets shot?
What if the guy shoots him immediately though?
That'd be crazy.
The hermit notices the old whaler standing on the dock waiting for him.
Oh my gosh, it's his ototo.
Little brother, you're home.
I'm so sorry.
I was so foolish.
We both were.
Come on inside.
Let me get your bags.
The two brothers walk away down the dock.
One of them pauses for a moment and turns back to you.
Oh, stranger.
If you find any more debris that needs clearing, I'm working on making some more packed explosives.
Come by the old whaling yard anytime.
Whaling yard!
This is free, right?
Packed explosives?
I hope you can put it to good use wherever you find cars.
Oh, more packs!
There's a lot of them.
Oh the first one is free?
Come on mister, I just reunited you with your...
brother.
Your brother of all time.
Please mister.
Please, everybody's...
Can't I be the only customer that gets them for free?
He always wanted a brother.
Use explosives.
Light the fuse.
The debris crumbles away.
He always wanted a brother.
Sapphire earrings.
Nice.
And this.
Oh my gosh.
What could it be?
Since you're so obsessed with me, can you help me decide whether or not to acquire a ten foot orca plushie that is a thousand bucks?
Orca!
No!
Orca, as your financial advisor, I must tell you.
Don't buy the ten foot orca.
Ten foot.
You couldn't even take it with you to things.
Or you could, but you wouldn't be able to take it on a ship or anything.
Oh gosh, I have boats on the brain, that's all I can think about.
Uh oh.
Let's go to sleep.
You...
If you try to take it to an event, that's like...
You have to travel by flight?
What's the point?
Dang it.
What a steal.
Stop, you guys!
You're such bad influences.
I'm selling my stuff.
It's like a hundred dollars per foot.
Sell all fish.
Alright.
Goodbye!
The collector is this way.
I think it should be even more expensive.
I think it should be 10k.
That's just my personal opinion.
Big money, big money, big money.
Damn it, this thing...
What?
Tetris.
Get Tetris.
An investment?
Everybody would know that it's...
Actually, maybe you do get it.
Maybe you do get it.
We need a bigger boat.
It's time for the boat.
We need the third boat upgrade.
Hello, mister.
It's been a really long time.
It's been like a whole year.
Sorry I've been gone.
So you've returned.
I wasn't sure you were coming back.
Me neither.
You drag the massive music box into the room.
Gouging the wooden floorboards beneath it.
The collector doesn't seem to mind.
He's focused on the box.
Surrender the music box.
You found this at the cliffs, didn't you?
Yes.
Ah, excellent.
This should make future return journeys a little more swift.
Allow me.
He selects one of the silver ribbons trailing from the crimson-bound book, opening it to some unseen page.
Wait, yeah, did we get a new power?
Turning to catch the dim light, he whispers the words on the page.
After a few seconds, you feel your stomach drop suddenly, as though thrown high by a wave.
He closes the book and turns his attention back to you.
Manifest.
The reef at Stellar Basin may have caught and accumulated some wreckage.
Search around that area.
I'll mark a location on your map.
Anything else?
What did you do to me?
The book holds power from the deep.
I merely extended it to you.
Manifest.
Use of these words will induce a trance-like state.
While in this state, time will pass in the blink of an eye.
When it is over, you will find yourself here.
As always, I caution against overusing this.
Selectively and strategically utilize it when you need it the most.
Interesting.
What are you going to do with these relics?
Why, collecting them, of course.
An investment for times to come.
Will it, like, kill all my fish?
Where should I... Oh, I know where to look for them.
Oh, why can't you search for them?
The ocean no longer wishes to cooperate.
As the waves are unsafe for me, you will be my surrogate.
Weird.
Let's take a look at these trinkets.
Oh, okay.
He doesn't want my junk.
Zero downsides!
That's huge!
So now we say to go to Stellar Basin.
Which we tried before.
And we shall try again.
But before that...
I want to start gathering some supplies again.
Such as, like, wood and scrap.
I want to get us ready for...
I know I saw some wood over here.
I want to start getting us ready for...
When we upgrade our ship.
Since that will come before we know it.
Hold on.
I think...
I have... Do I have trinkets?
Oh yeah, I do.
Sell all.
Alright, 46 bucks.
Let's go.
What do we need for hole 2?
You mean hole 3?
Quite a bit, actually.
We still need quite...
It's a lot of money, mostly.
It's mostly the cash.
But...
Oh!
The lighthouse keeper is waiting for you on the dock, looking displeased.
I saw you sailing out towards the horizon, crossing that deep expanse.
Do you really think that's wise?
I've been doing this everyday, lady.
It was fine.
Maybe this time.
You need to be more careful.
Even you, with all your experience, cannot truly know the ocean.
Nobody can.
I gotta upgrade my engine first?
Really?
Abruptly, she walks away.
Her eyes scan the water as she walks along the dock.
Oh yeah.
Does the mayor got anything for me?
Sell my fish.
Alright, we're already at 500, though.
Not bad, not bad.
Cause...
I still need to do the engine space.
And then the hull.
You guys say upgrade the engine, but...
To what?
Like...
I have no research parts.
So I can't really do anything there.
Unless you mean like...
Buying the rest of the jet drive engines.
My storage.
This is 15.
I could uninstall it.
Oh my gosh!
I forgot to sell this!
Let's go sell it.
Speed.
That's so crazy.
Oh, we can just do that.
Magic fish.
That guy is crazy looking.
Wait, what is this thing?
Deplete a total of 25 fishing spots.
Fun.
Guy is a winner.
Chicken dinner.
Trader.
Sell.
Alright, now we go...
Actually, let's go to my storage.
Let's throw these in storage.
I do have to also do repairs.
So we'll...
Go back.
Maybe I will buy stuff.
Buy like a new part for the engine.
And then we'll head back to...
Wherever the heck that guy told us to go.
164!
Nice!
Oh my gosh, you guys.
Wait.
We almost have enough money.
I mean, I still have to buy this thing.
But still!
Crazy.
Okay.
What if...
How much is this?
$2.55 I could buy two of them.
Oh my gosh, my repair is $108!
It's so expensive!
We can also get one more space.
Which I have to get anyway, so I'm just gonna get it.
I was saving it just so that in case we...
Wanted this for fish, but...
We're just getting more jets.
We're getting more jets, baby!
But I can't afford it right now, so...
Before we go, I'm going to fish.
I'm gonna go find maybe...
Let's go get some oceanic fish.
Those guys are big money.
Like our little whaler friend.
Depleted, just kidding.
Is this oceanic?
I'm too lazy to take out my...
Too lazy to take out my...
Magnifying glass.
But I will now.
Just so I know where to go.
I saw something else.
I saw it.
It disappeared.
Wherever it went.
Go flounder.
Blue mackerel.
What's that?
A blue mackerel.
Sailfish!
Sailfish, ho!
Sailfish are good.
Hope you feel better soon.
Thank you!
I've been just chilling.
This actually is helping so much, I'm not gonna lie.
I feel so relaxed.
Thank you guys.
Uh oh.
Wait.
We can fit this.
We can make this work.
I might have to get rid of this guy though.
Are you kidding me?
Lower the sailfish one space.
It's always the sailfish.
It really is.
This guy is a thorn in my side.
This jeopardy theme place.
I'm taking this guy back if we can only take two of them.
If only I didn't have this one jet right here.
I could get rid of our spotlight.
Okay, bye bronze whaler.
That was unfortunate.
Wait.
I'm closer to Ingfeld.
Ugh.
I don't even remember.
I think I was just getting money, right?
Use more explosives here.
But my money...
They're 35 each.
Yeah, I need the...
See, 207 bucks.
It's not bad.
It's not bad at all.
This still has two days left.
Very nice.
It can save you a lot of money too.
I know.
I believe you.
Oh, she sells them too.
Good to know.
We can get a new light.
Wait, should we sell our old one and get the new light?
I think so.
Zemir, does the traveling merchant look like Spinelli from Recess?
I see it!
It's the beanie.
Oh, I almost was able to forward this.
Okay, let's get...
Let's...We...We...We...
We will...We...
We will get more big fish.
And buy jet, then continue.
Where was...
What was that?
Oh, tiger mackerel.
Oceanic perch in the coastal.
Don't lie to me!
Sailfish.
Torto!
What do you guys think?
Alright, here we go.
I'm getting greedy.
Got him.
Literally can fit one at a time.
That's okay though.
Now we leave.
Actually it's depleted anyway.
Or we can fish a little bit more.
Such a nice and chill stream to enjoy my birthday!
NCG happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday NCG goggles!
Happy, happy, happy birthday!
Nice.
Oops.
Let's just get some extra fish while we are here.
The more money, the more honey.
Sorry.
I literally took that entire guy's family and then left him.
Oh boy, I'm lonesome.
How much?
236 babies.
Let's go.
Honestly, even if I can only just do one sailfish, it's worth it.
It's so worth it.
Have a combined engine speed of 75 knots!
What?
Alright, let's get some explosives I suppose.
Sis.
Explosives I suppose, sis.
Can I start putting... I guess I should start putting stuff in here.
1, 2, 3, 1...
Look at that!
Nice!
We got a good amount here already.
Just over half.
Cool.
So many knots.
And just the refined metal.
Can you find this in the ocean or can you only buy it?
You see some debris nearby, you do?
Where are you at?
Holy fast!
Oh my gosh, you guys are speed!
I'll just deplete it.
This is the most fish here ever.
The biggest fish family.
I don't think we can move the light to a different spot.
That's kind of the thing.
Like it's kind of, you know, that's where it is.
You can find it but it's rare.
Oh, there's some hidden by explosives.
I see.
Look behind the waterfall.
Oh, ok.
I'll look behind the waterfall.
And...
Yeah, it's kind of like with these, with the light, it has to be there.
Unfortunately.
That's just how the game is.
Alright.
Undock.
Behind the waterfall.
Do I need explosives for that or...
Should I go?
Should I explode this?
Should I explode these parts?
There's two of them.
Why not?
Yeah?
Hold on, my chat just froze.
I'm sorry guys, one moment please.
One moment please.
Are you guys enjoying?
Did you guys have a nice weekend?
I hope so.
We are forging.
Looks like there's a shiny too behind the rocks.
I thought, it looked like to me that it was another part to...
To blow up, not gonna lie.
Let's see.
Oh wait, I see.
That looks like, maybe...
Use explosives.
It looks like that could be the special stuff that we need.
It looks kind of like the shape, no?
Oh yeah, yeah!
It
really was!
Slow turn.
No way!
It was worth it.
I need to get more explosives.
Explosives.
Yeah, the low, low price of 34 instead of...
However much it was.
How much does Zeus sell it for?
425!
Yeah, yeah.
I think she is literally scamming us.
Drift.
Behind the waterfall.
Hopefully that guy is not around here.
I'm scared of him.
Oh, he is totally around here.
There he is!
Where is the waterfall?
What waterfall?
Listen to the drive a lot.
There is a lot of sounds coming from over there.
In the middle?
The center?
The middle.
Big clearing.
Is that where I found the...
Do you mean where I found the treasure before?
In here?
Please.
Oh my goodness.
Wait, this is where I just came from.
The whale crest.
I think I can find that from outside.
I went right underneath him!
Or he went right underneath me!
Oh god.
He is on my ass.
I can't see anything.
Behind the waterfall.
You guys!
The rotten chest sits atop a pile of rubble at the back of the cave.
I just have to get out unscathed.
Maybe I'll be okay.
What is that?
That looks like a...
I can't get him.
Dang it.
How the hell am I supposed to get out of here?
It's an oarfish.
Legendary guy.
I can tell from the way he looks.
It's an oarfish.
Okay, we got to get home.
I can't see.
I don't know which way I'm going.
But we will find our way home.
I don't know where I am.
Oh, I know where I am.
I know where I am!
This way.
There is wood there.
Keep note!
Lady, I need a lot of help.
I need a lot of help, please.
Lady.
So much to repair.
That's probably how much money we'll get from the balloons.
Thank you so much for the 10 gifted!
But you know what?
It's honestly worth it because this is still cheaper.
You know?
It's still cheaper.
Whoops, sorry, my bad.
Floating dock.
And there's two woods.
Honestly, we might be able to do this.
Well, we will be able to fill it up with the supplies, but definitely not the cost.
But that's okay.
We're broke.
Yeah, we're pretty broke.
We've been without teleport, but teleport only takes us all...
I don't wanna use the teleport unless like...
It's like serious because it's gonna take us all the way back...
Like over there.
So I don't wanna just use it like... Oh, I need to teleport!
But...
But, but, but, but...
I might use it actually so that we can go sell the doubloons faster.
Or...
We sail and we get another sailfish and we sell that bad boy.
For some good money.
You guys are so obsessed with my butt.
We don't have space right now.
Watch...
And observe.
Oh wait, can I...
Oh wait.
And we should with even still the engine, right?
I don't know actually.
Actually, you might be right.
We'll go see.
I guess we'll see.
Only one way to find out, exactly.
It would be a damn shame though.
It would be a real shame.
Oh no, this isn't a sailfish.
Hold on.
Maybe we can find another one.
Where is home?
Oh, I'm going the wrong way.
Home is this way.
Bronze whaler.
What is that thing?
Wait, is that one right there?
Is my guy broken?
No.
Oh, that's the bronze whaler.
We can get that guy.
Are you a bronze whaler?
I can maybe...
One bronze whaler?
You
were always such a problem!
I thought about fishing until I get a rare, but I also was like, it's starting to get a little dark.
A little spooky scary.
It sounds like it's talking.
It's so scary sounding.
Did I have any... Oh yeah, I have the doubloons.
Oh wait, my bad.
Trader, please buy my doubloons.
For 172?
Whenever I see abyssal in this, I think of the abyssals from conchole.
Oh, I think abysmal.
It's just like...
Kind of like...
Like it just sucks down there.
God, nobody wants to be in the abysmal.
Is there any guys I can get right here?
What are you?
You're a little eel.
Anything?
Let's see.
Anything good out there?
Blacktip reef shark.
It's a little far, but it might be good.
Right here.
Sorry.
Oh!
Was that guy honking at me?
What's that sound?
I don't like it.
Honk honk.
Let's get some, you know... Oh, I got a creepy crawly one too.
Perfect.
Let's just fill up.
Very good.
What was the music for?
Lousy weather lately.
Almost makes you not want to get out of bed.
You and I, we've got to do it, eh?
We're what keeps people from going hungry.
$462!
Guys, we're just $100 away!
We're just $100 away from...
From being able to get the upgrade.
Let's go!
And what is that upgrade?
It will add...
Upgrades your vessel to a tier 3 hull and adds 9 new cargo spaces.
Hull can sustain 1 additional impact.
Plus 15.
And...
See?
All we need to do...
Is go get...
A...
What's that guy's name?
A sailfish.
Didn't I say I was going to go to the other world?
Or to the other world?
The Stellar Basin.
Maybe I should go there.
Let's just go.
It's...
Not that way.
This way.
Yes.
Oh, the moon!
This is my first time seeing it.
Thank you so much for the 5 gifted.
We're human.
I wish my speed didn't make the time go faster.
You know?
I feel like that's kind of unfair.
No?
You're punishing me for having supersonic everything?
For being too good at the game?
You're punishing me?
What's this?
Disturbed water.
Disturbed.
Should make time go slower.
Right, that's what I'm saying.
What's this thing?
Shapes in the deep.
An anchor flag.
Oh, neat.
What?
Have I never noticed this before?
Oh my gosh, it's this actual Titanic.
Titanic.
What are you guys?
A barracuda.
Let's get some more.
I think these guys will sell well.
One more.
Awesome.
Is it inside there?
Yes.
Our lady friend is over there.
But before we get to her, we can blow this up.
Use explosives.
Alright.
Oh, there's more than one.
Who's barking?
Is that in game?
It is in game.
Oh my goodness.
Where's the dog?
I don't like the creepy music.
I hear a dog.
I don't hear a dog anymore.
Creepy.
Spooky.
Do I have enough space for this?
I don't know.
I might be making a mistake.
I have like no space for this guy.
Hold on.
We can make this work.
As long as nobody attacks me.
Okay, world.
We might have to sacrifice a barracuda.
One barracuda sacrifice is worth.
In my opinion.
That wasn't the abnormal one?
Oh, it wasn't?
It's fine.
It's okay.
I panicked.
I thought something was coming towards me.
Oh, you're right.
It's just a glowing octopus.
Oopsie.
Oh well.
All good.
And with that, my friends.
Net space, rod space, cargo space, engine space, light space.
I'm starting to get hungry though.
Oh, oops.
No, that's not what I wanted to do.
Shipyard!
Look at all that room!
Nice.
What sucks though is that I haven't really gotten any more research bars.
So, I'm kind of like, not able to kind of improve my stuff.
Why did I move my rod over there?
Slaps boat.
This baby can fit so many sailfish in.
I have to start buying them regularly.
Oh, maybe.
There are a limited amount of those per area.
I think, honestly, at this rate...
If we get a couple sailfish on board, we can buy, you know...
We can buy one, so it's not so bad.
Oh, I gotta get the explosive so we can... The trees are going crazy.
Let me get the explosive so we can...
Go clear out the other... There was like another side of that area.
Seemed like just a shortcut, but...
Oh, repair!
Sorry, I forgot.
It's okay though, because...
Where's the dog?
Oh yeah, this is just like a shortcut.
Might save my butt sometime though.
Sounds like he's to your left.
Oh!
I have my headphones on wrong!
I was like, no, I'm pretty sure he's on my right.
There he is!
There is a skinny brown dog leaping around the shallows.
Occasionally it lunges at the water, snapping at some small silvery fish.
Its technique is ineffective.
You jump off the boat into high water.
The dog stops chasing fish and focuses on you.
Throw some fish towards the dog.
You throw some scraps into the water near the dog.
It pounces at the splash and swallows seawater.
Pet the dog!
You're too far away to pet the dog.
Approach slowly.
You wade towards the shore.
As you get nearer, the dog backs a little away.
It sits.
Slowly.
You start to walk closer to the dog, but it runs away nervously and hides in some bushes.
After a few moments, it emerges again.
Throw some fish.
You throw some fish.
Fish land in the sand.
The dog eats them.
Along with a mouthful of sand.
Call for the dog.
You make soft, encouraging noises.
And the dog cautiously approaches.
Hold some fish in my hand.
The dog approaches and begins licking at them.
Pet the dog!
You reach out and gently pet the dog.
It's eyes follow your hand and seems to understand that you're not a threat.
It seems to be enjoying it.
What do you mean leave?
As you're wading... Oh, you hear slashing of four legs cutting through the water.
The dog!
Let it follow you!
Oh!
We got a dog!
Pursuit... wait, pursuit updated.
You lift the dog onto the deck.
It walks around briefly before curling into a ball looking up at you.
Maybe you can find this dog a more permanent home.
Who wants this dog?
Find the dog a home.
It's bound to be hungry.
What?
We saved him.
Look how cute this guy is though.
He looks so sleepy.
Guys, what should I have for dinner tonight?
Fish.
Look at that thing on the left.
It's crazy looking.
I want the hammerhead shark.
I don't know.
We probably can...we're around this area.
We can find him maybe.
Wait.
Oh dammit.
Wait, I don't think we can catch him now though.
Because...I don't think we can catch him now then because he...
He's gonna be too big, isn't he?
I caught him.
He's not too big.
Not for my boat.
The dog is in more danger than ever.
No, he was the one driving.
He took hold of my...
My ship.
I wish that even turning didn't affect the time.
He scared me!
I got good.
I'm starting to get pretty hungry.
I might need a snack.
Luckily, I have some popcorn.
A little snack break.
Can we bring him on board too?
I wish.
216!
That's what I'm talking about, baby.
I'm sorry dog, you go to storage.
Now we...prepare.
84 bucks.
Expensive.
Sorry, when I get so hungry, my blood sugar gets like crazy.
If I had blood.
That's how I describe it to you guys.
Ecto-sugar.
Take your time.
Thank you!
Just need a couple mouthfuls.
I have to figure out what I want for dinner though.
I don't know yet.
Our map.
So the guy...the next thing that we need is definitely in the middle.
But how do I get it?
I still need to talk to the research outpost.
Sushi.
I had sushi the other day.
What if I had it again?
It's just expensive, you know.
A little pricey.
Look at that thing.
Don't touch me.
Is this the research outpost?
Right here?
Eel sushi.
Yummy!
It's my favorite.
Oh, I didn't put my net out.
My bad.
I'll put it out.
The laboratory is in ruins with equipment and research papers strewn about the place.
Where do you want to look?
The cupboards?
Nice!
Prototype parts, but you can't use them right now.
On the other side of the table you find a hastily scrawled note.
It reads, Not safe.
Expect retaliation imminently.
Evacuating to fort.
There are cracks in the base of the structure that grow to large gashes as you follow them along to the walls.
Something extremely large and powerful created these holes.
You slowly reach your arm into one.
Research part.
I don't really have a favorite food.
Maybe tacos.
I haven't had Taco Bell in a minute.
Old generator sputters and ticks over.
We have two research parts guys.
What do we do?
I could do the large net.
That might be pretty nice.
New rod.
I do want an abyssal rod.
How do I get to it?
Where is the mangrove?
The rod in the middle catches almost everything.
You're close to unlocking the abyssal rod in this area.
They'll give me one.
I feel like I should finish the net.
It's like free money.
I still have one left.
Actually, I'm going to use it just in case.
I don't know.
I don't expect something to happen, but you never know.
You never know.
Let's go for...
We don't have storage here.
There's no storage.
Try the pots.
I need to use the crab pots, don't I?
I really need to get the crab pots, don't I?
Catch research parts?
Really?
An investment.
Maybe then I should get the large pot.
Fish tacos for dinner.
I don't know where to get fish tacos.
I don't know where to get some.
We researched two things!
There was nothing here.
Nothing that I expected to be here.
There's also this little area.
A little island to the west.
Nothing here.
That's not as little as I thought it would be.
It's like a castle.
Wait, they did say go back to the fort.
Is this the fort?
Oh,
my net.
Thank you.
There it is.
Researcher.
A fisherman all the way out here?
Strange.
Well, it's a pleasure to meet you all the same.
I've not seen another soul in months.
In fact, I could do with your help if you had the time.
Yeah, what is it?
I need help collecting samples to study.
It was originally posted at the research outpost in the interior of the basin, but it was attacked.
A large creature emerged from the depths and destroyed the outpost.
Now it rests in the center of the basin.
I fled here and have been making due as best I can.
I had to leave most of my equipment behind.
Oh yeah, I looted that place.
What a burger.
I had a burger yesterday.
Now my research has come to a halt.
Take a look at this list of specimens.
Oh, I got that guy.
Aurora jellyfish.
I guess I've caught that too.
I don't know when.
Please drop them off here.
You might need to experiment with different fishing strategies to collect all of them.
Okay.
Tell me about yourself.
I don't think there's much to say.
I studied biological sciences at Iron Haven College.
It was a struggle.
There were no other female students in the department that year.
Or the year before.
Or the year before that.
It's hard not to feel like an outsider in an environment like that, you know?
You probably don't.
Okay, gosh.
When I graduated, I managed to land a job at the Northern Biological Research Society.
And then, well, I was posted here by myself.
What are you researching?
I thought I would relish the peace and quiet.
But I miss having company.
Do you want a dog?
I've always had someone, or at least a pet.
Out here, it's just machines.
Is there anything else?
We have a dog.
That was the fastest quest ever.
What sort of creature attacked you?
I got the sense that it was attacking the research outpost itself rather than me specifically.
I suspect it was disturbed by some of my monitoring equipment.
There were dozens of machines running there, all powered by a noisy generator.
It was huge, larger than any other marine species I've ever studied.
It attacked with tentacles, so I guess some sort of octopus or squid.
Or an anemone.
One of my research vessels was moored around the back of the station.
So I managed to slip away in that while it was tearing apart the front.
There was a lot of valuable data and equipment left there.
But I'm not going back.
I can't.
I won't face it again.
Have you noticed anything else unusual since you arrived?
Now that you mention it, I've been so preoccupied with the attack and having to rebuild here, I'd almost forgotten.
I found these letters from my sister.
She sent them to me while I was studying before...
Before she...
The researcher went quiet for a moment and stares off to the side.
Oh no, her sister...
Anyway, I kept finding them amongst my papers.
I don't remember packing them, but I must have.
I started finding them more frequently.
They turned up in my collection nets.
In my sampling tubes.
What?
They were letters I'd never seen before.
But they were her writing.
They were in her name.
That's weird.
They were saying things, talking about things that happened after she died.
I can't explain it.
That's weird.
Oh...
This dog needs a home, do you want it?
A dog?
Oh gosh, let me see.
The dog bounds over to the researcher.
She crouches down to pet the dog, grinning.
The dog licks her chin in response.
I could definitely take this one off your hands.
And I'd love the company.
Are you sure?
Nah, I don't want the dog.
Yeah, I take the dog.
He needs some medicine.
He needs a vet, for real.
We're going to be such good friends.
He can be my assistant.
Suddenly the dog stands...
upright and begins to retch.
Its stomach heaving.
I told you he needed a vet!
Seconds later, it vomits a wet glob onto the floor.
Something glistens through the mucus.
That's interesting.
I suppose that's yours.
Thanks.
I can clean the rest up.
Don't worry about it.
Yeah, it's your dog.
Let's see real quick.
Because I know...
Collect all the samples.
Glowing octopus, firefly squid.
Are these all... These all seem like night time critters.
Firefly squid.
Yep, they're all night time.
Time to undock.
And look around.
What are you?
Can't touch you.
Glowing octopus.
Let's just go inside.
Does she care if they're rotting?
She's not going to eat them, so like...
It's probably fine if they're a little gross, no?
It's fine?
Ok, cool.
I like this area.
It's pretty.
I didn't need to do anything.
Let's go.
Let's see.
I like that we can see the lighthouse from here.
Good job, net.
Minto wins by doing nothing.
That's the research.
Oh, we got more.
Where is everything?
Actually... Oh wait, here we go.
It's hard to see.
For some of these guys, you know?
Maybe we'll get the creepy one that I was promised before.
I promised creepy guy.
I'm just going to keep collecting them.
Ah!
Medusa octopus.
Eight snapping mouths crawl over each other at the behest of a silent master.
Nice.
Creepy guy, creepy guy.
In the end, it all worked out.
You?
Oh my gosh, we would get so much money for all of these.
I must sell all but one.
Do not hold F.
I'm not, I'm not.
Large crab pot.
What is it that I bought?
The net.
Uninstall.
Reinstall.
Take you.
Should I repair it first?
Yeah, we'll repair it so we get full money amount.
Because it's only $20.
And then we'll buy the new one.
It's coastal and shallow.
Okay, good.
So, repair.
Oh, it's still the same.
That's disappointing.
Sell.
Buy.
I didn't realize.
We can...
We can do this.
I just need to get some cloth and some wood and we'll be...
Sorry.
We will have more space.
We're okay.
I didn't mess up.
It's all according to the plan.
Early investment.
Exactly.
There is 100% wood and cloth here.
Speak of the devil.
Lumber.
I'll even get a second one.
Maybe a third if it allows.
Oops, sorry.
I saw the wrong thing.
Yeah!
Trust the plan.
Exactly, exactly.
What is this?
Big money.
That's what that is.
There
we go.
Believe in the Minky that believes in you.
Exactly.
Okay.
Researcher.
Your specimen.
Where did the Aurora Jellyfish go?
The music is reminding me of that Naruto song.
Well it's fine because I didn't even get the Firefly Squid.
And we needed that guy.
Naruto's sad music.
Well shoot.
In the meantime, I'm gonna sell this shark and then I'm gonna find some...
I'm gonna find some cloth!
And then everything will not be important.
Not!
Don't laugh at my teeth or something.
Okay.
Oh, wrong thing.
Any second now we'll see cloth.
Immediately.
Any second now cloth will be on the menu.
Any second.
Any second now there will be cloth.
It's probably right behind here.
This is the Angry Crab.
Sounds like even the monkeys are laughing at me.
What is that?
The kookaburra?
Look at that!
The thing that I needed.
This guy is evil?
He's so beautiful.
What if I gave her the wrong guy?
Like that thing.
Does she know that there is like freaky things in the water here?
I'll take two just in case.
Is that...
The one time I don't need wood.
Please, game.
Would you be so kind?
I don't even know how to find the jellies.
Like the pretty one that I'm looking for.
I don't want this guy coming after me.
Jellies are net only?
No.
Surely you jest.
No way.
I got a trophy Medusa?
How much is that guy worth?
I'm gonna go sell him and see.
Ok,
so we need cloth like 100% right now.
Oh my goodness.
You guys, it wasn't part of the plan.
It wasn't part of the plan.
I messed up.
Bad.
I think I messed up.
Nice.
Sell all but one.
He's still fresh.
Just in case she needs a new one.
Actually no, I'm just gonna sell him.
How much money do I have?
Almost 800 dollars.
Oops, sorry.
No,
don't do that.
There's gotta be cloth around here somewhere.
What are you?
Your jewelry.
Sapphire ring.
Just like the dog barfed up.
Ma'am, the wood.
We don't need wood right now.
We need cloth.
Maybe like over there.
So painful.
It's so painful.
Oh yeah, we got this too.
We are engaged to be married.
My god.
Then you remember what you said.
Is that the ring that I found?
Or the one that the dog barfed up?
Who is she writing this to?
To warrant spanning multiple entries.
Oh, she really did write 6th and 7th.
Research.
Here's your little guy.
Okay.
Do you have any cloth?
Can I have the clothes off your back, ma'am?
Can I please have whatever you're wearing?
Maybe there's some cloth over here.
Maybe there's like a camp or something, you know?
Oh, the music is exciting.
I like it.
Where are we anyway?
Can you go off the map?
I just noticed.
How far can we go?
Nothing.
Yeah.
Worst tiny island ever.
We're almost to the twisted strand.
You can go pretty far.
You can.
That looks like a shipwreck.
That looks pretty bad.
That looks like no survivors.
That looks like maybe there's a skeleton wearing...
of something.
Oh my god!
Wait.
That's not a shipwreck.
That's a plane wreck.
We got...
What the hell is a sextant?
Oh!
Oh
my god.
I thought you had clothes.
Guys, this is looking mighty unfortunate.
This is looking so unfortunate.
We're gonna have to backtrack like crazy.
Oh wait.
Woah.
Let's sell our new treasures.
First let's catch a spooky fish.
Thank you!
I'll read it in a second.
Give me a second.
Wait.
Can I fit several guys here?
There we go.
Hey, where's my spooky guy?
What?
Depleted?
Aw man.
Giant enemy crab.
Yeah, we got scammed for real.
Hello sir.
Please buy this tool.
That has no...
explicit meaning.
And also, this ring that was barfed up by a dog.
And this ring that might have belonged to a family or something.
I don't know.
Yes.
Oh no!
No wait!
No no no no no.
Change flag.
Next page.
Pirate flag.
Thank you.
You guys...
What a wrench in my plans.
I'm sorry.
Wow, we have a thousand dollars though.
What should I buy?
Hello.
That crimson glow in the sky seems to have gone away.
The air feels quieter now.
We're settled.
Have you noticed?
New net.
I'm working on it.
I need two flags.
Five.
I don't want to buy the old net.
It's a waste of my money.
I'm, I'm, I'm...
I'm... what's the word?
I'm...
sticking with this one.
It's not stubborn.
I mean, yes, but...
Yeah, I'm committed.
I'm committed.
That's what I was trying to think of.
I'm committed now.
Okay.
Some sweet cloth.
Depleted.
Cloth!
Some more cloth.
Actually...
We can always count on this area to have stuff.
Why not get some more scrap and everything too, right?
Why not get everything that we can get here?
Oh, shoot!
Sorry, I read it wrong.
Japanese word for cringe is...
Absolutely.
Oh, there's more?
Wow.
Yeah!
More scrap!
And we'll even get some wood.
We'll get everything.
We will be not without supplies.
So much scrap.
I know.
We really loaded up on the stuff.
I wish they gave us more cloth though.
I'm not gonna lie.
Why were they so stingy on the cloth?
Oh!
A research part.
Hello?
Lucky.
Everyone I've seen play this always struggles with cloth.
Really?
So it's not just me?
That makes me feel a bit better.
What was I working on?
You!
Can you imagine once we get the heavy duty net?
And then we'll be able to get Oceanic and then we can get a bunch of big boys.
What's that?
What was that?
I just panicked.
I panicked.
What?
Was it the other ship?
It was a friend.
Yes.
Wait a second.
Is this a big fish?
I'll take it.
A bronze whaler.
I'll do more.
Oh yeah.
It is time.
First we sell.
Okay.
Awesome.
Actually, I might grab...
Oh.
Well, hold on.
Before I...
You!
Oh.
No, no, no, no.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
Dry dock.
You!
Net space.
And you!
Purchase.
Okay!
Woohoo!
We did it.
A friend.
Why no friend sound?
We could also do the light space.
Or the engine space.
We could do one or the other.
Alright.
Ma'am.
Install her.
Six hours!
Install equipment into every slot of your ship is what the achievement I just got was.
Okay.
We did it.
Perfect.
We could go for more cargo space.
Wowee.
That cleared up everything.
Again, once again, too cloth.
But...
But if I...
Hold on.
Well, I didn't sleep.
I doubt there will be more over there.
But there might be some around us.
There might be some in our vicinity that we can...
Oh!
Perhaps...
You know...
Grab...
In the...
Many eyed mackerel.
Oops, I didn't mean to grab it again.
There we go.
Well, it's depleted anyway.
Oh, my net!
Yes, thank you.
We worked hard for this guy.
Around here?
That is...
What appears to be...
Oh my god, please don't hit the...
Please don't hit the wall.
Metal scrap.
I'll keep dredging.
Back home, please.
What the hell are you?
Oh my gosh.
I think we are really crazy.
We are zooming, we are zooming.
Oh!
My, you look exhausted.
You are not forgetting to get some sleep, are you?
As I always say, taking frequent breaks is an important part of being productive.
Yes, what are you doing up at 1 AM, mister?
I'm going to sleep!
Is everyone going to tell me how tired I look?
Yeah!
They are all telling me how tired I look.
That's so funny.
Even the lighthouse keeper?
Nah, she doesn't care.
Have you seen anything significant from the lighthouse recently?
The fog.
It's behaving...
It's as though it's reacting to the light that cut through it.
It swirls and crashes against the edges.
From the top of the lighthouse, I can see dark figures.
Seething in the thickest tracks.
Out beyond Little Marrow, where the lights dwindle.
Of all that I've seen, your lights seem to anger them the most.
Interesting.
They're seething out there.
I guess it is time for us to get a new fishing line, huh?
Start with that one.
You look a bit sleepy.
Are they telling me to stop playing the game?
Never!
What if I go back over here?
Of all
the aberrations you've seen so far in the game, which one would you be most curious to eat despite the consequences?
To eat?
Dang, they didn't respawn so quickly.
One could be...
You know...
Hopeful.
Have I been over here?
The one curious to eat.
What does exotic count?
Oh, those are the rare guys, huh?
Those look pretty rare.
Eww, grotesque mackerel.
Lumpy.
All-seeing cod.
There's a different kind of cod we haven't caught.
Third kind of cod we haven't caught.
I'm a fan of eels, so maybe any sort of eel.
Like the host eel.
Actually, no, I don't like fish eggs.
Shard ray.
I want that as a pet.
I don't want that to eat.
The perch looks so bad.
The bearded mackerel.
Eww, enthralled stonefish looks horrible.
Decaying blackmouth.
Not gonna lie, it looks really yummy.
The sprouting eel is also very cute.
Woah, what is...
Woah, I want that one.
Number 97.
Radiant squid.
I would eat that.
I would eat the hell out of that.
The radiant squid.
I think everybody can agree.
Yeah.
Look at that tiny boat right there.
Are you friend?
Why is your boat so small?
I'm not shaming, I'm just asking.
Who goes there?
A monster.
Oh my god, are we gonna be mean?
Very funny.
What do you want?
I was just checking to see if you're okay.
Do I seem okay?
No, I'm very much not okay.
I'm supposed to be delivering this package to Little Marrow, but I'm being stalked.
A huge leviathan lurks in these deep waters.
I've seen it.
It hung in the water, its gaping mouth just below the boat.
It would have swallowed this vessel whole if I hadn't bolted for the shallows.
I'm not going any further into this accursed island chain.
I'll deliver it.
You would?
Well, that would work, I guess.
This is actually death stranding.
This is a strand game for real.
The courier pushes a lumpy brown package through the door hole.
It squelches slightly as you take it into your hands.
Dark fluid oozes from one corner.
Okay, I was hoping that I was not... that I was just seeing things.
Thank you, stranger.
This is bound for the dock worker at Little Marrow.
I'm not sure what's inside, but listen.
I know this sounds crazy, but sometimes I think I can hear the faintest of whispers coming from it.
Now, I'm not supposed to be transporting live goods.
I don't have the equipment for it.
So just be careful with this thing, whatever it is.
Here, why don't you take this too?
We got a book.
I'll be on my way whenever the coast is clear.
Safe travels.
Cool.
It's been a minute since we've gotten a book.
Now, who is the...
Who is the dock worker?
Cloth right there.
There wasn't cloth in there, was it?
Scrap.
Behind the rock.
I'm gonna double check, but you better not be bamboozling me.
Wait, oh...
Well, that might be it, actually.
I think you're right.
Nope.
Ah, dang it.
It looked like it a lot.
It did look like it.
I'll be honest.
Random.
No!
What's this one?
This one looks like some more...
Whatever, whatever.
Yeah.
Probably some more, like, iron.
Iron stuff.
Broken monocle.
This is definitely not, but I'll grab it anyway.
Because we're already on our way over there.
Another broken monocle.
A lot of nerds died here.
What if it's not a monocle?
What if it's the second half of the glasses?
Something after me?
Wait.
Back.
Look how cute they are.
Oh, they're traveling.
Oh, we'll get the sunset in the background.
Let's roll.
Yay!
I thought something was after me.
Can't trust this game.
A dock worker.
That guy over here?
Oh yeah, here he is.
How's the day treating you?
I got a package for you.
A delivery, eh?
Oh, it's a big one.
Let me see.
He takes the large package and examines it gently with his hands.
He lifts it to one ear and listens for a while.
He seems satisfied.
Much appreciated, friend.
Now if you'll excuse me, wish me luck.
What is everybody doing?
He turns and hurries up down the dock without another word to you.
Or compensation.
Jerk.
I don't have anything in storage, right?
Erm...
What should we do?
Let's go sell our fish.
And then we'll go back to the lady.
We'll find cloth elsewhere as well.
We'll find more cloth eventually.
It's okay.
Alright.
And sleep.
Full speed at the dock.
Yeah, I don't have time to waste.
I don't have time to waste.
It's like this way, right?
Yeah, pretty much.
There might be some over here actually.
Let's check here.
Are you oceanic?
Tempting.
Dang it, it's wood.
Of course, when I don't need anymore wood.
But I shall grab it regardless.
I'm such a fan of this game, you guys.
This is the comfort I've been craving.
Silver necklace.
It's neat, yeah.
I have room for this.
It's probably fine.
There are so many birds.
Lucky!
Do you ever think about how goofy is a father?
I don't want to think about what he's doing to become a father.
You got me all distracted.
And how can I... I think about this every now and then.
No!
Why would you think about this?
Another research part!
You guys were killing it.
Oh my god.
Wait.
This is insane.
Let's get out of here.
Is that guy going to come towards me?
Oh oh.
That was so scary.
What did I lose?
I lost some scrap, but that's ok.
Scrap is scrap.
We have so much scrap.
We'll lose the scrap.
Yeah, we'll lose the scrap.
Scrap is probably the best thing we could have lost there, honestly.
We can get a new thing though.
I'm almost tempted to start research on this guy even.
It's the same amount.
I'm gonna do it.
Thank you.
If you want the DLC, get it before you beat the game.
There's no story spoilers.
It adds more stuff to do in each zone.
But if your ship is upgraded when you start the DLC, it feels too easy.
I see, I see.
I will keep that in mind.
Thank you.
Ok.
Alright.
Let's go actually to where we were going to go before.
That dang ship really spoiled my mood.
That guy threw a wrench in my plans.
Thank you.
Maple.
Maple sides.
Gosh, we make it there so quickly now.
Maybe there's some cloth here?
Right in here?
Cloth.
I don't think... I think that's scrap.
Yep.
No more scrap at the moment.
Thank you.
I'm full.
See, I wanna get these guys.
Look at that.
I can see them.
Alright, now we wait until night time.
We can get the jelly and then we can complete the mission.
And all is well.
What about this?
Is he gonna get mad at me?
He got mad at me.
Okay.
I think he got mad at me.
I just repaired you.
It's okay, we're making money as we swim along.
She just wanted to get grabbed by the tentacles a little bit.
As a treat.
I don't know if I'm in the tentacles.
How would you know?
I guess if you just see it and you're like ooh la la.
How do you know?
What the hell is making all that noise over there?
If you know, you know.
Alright, undock.
Catch more fish.
I can send you reference material.
You know, if you need a little study session.
This thing is so gross.
Nasty.
Ew, look at his face.
Alright, let's go sell these guys.
Ooh, it's red.
He's got your colors.
But like...
I don't look like a...
Like a zombie Mew...
Do I look like a Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtle to you?
What's this spooky music for?
Cut it out.
Cut it out, game.
It's like kind of my colors.
Stop it.
Donaminto.
Minta...Minta...
Wait.
Michelangelo.
Mintagelio.
Wait, I can't say it.
Can you say cowabunga?
Woo, 400 bucks.
Let's go.
Okay, I'm gonna buy this large crab pot now.
And we're gonna set it up...
We're gonna set it up...
Right here.
Does it matter if it's in like shallow or deep or whatever?
Like totally, dude.
What, do you guys see it?
The aurora borealis!
Oh my gosh, propose right now.
And then the dog will eat your ring.
And then it will throw it up.
Alright, there's time over here.
Minky, would you please...
Please use my family name.
Oh my god.
I gotta get away from the...
From the spooky mist.
What lies entirely in this basin?
Oh, what was that sound?
Oh, it's this.
Do you think we got it yet or...
Oh, we got that.
No, no, no.
No sir, no.
Check your net, that's what I'm about to do.
We got it!
About the specimens.
I'm glad she's still awake.
It's 1AM.
Thank you.
Looks like you've caught all the surface specimens I need.
Oh, the dog!
It eats the ring.
Oh no, he doesn't feel so good.
He threw up the ring.
And that is the circle of life.
I do need some from deeper down, but that's going to be a problem.
I don't have the equipment to catch anything deeper anyway.
I developed a device to retrieve samples from the abyssal zone.
This was over in the other research outpost before the attack.
I have an idea of how to keep the creature at bay long enough to collect those samples.
But while I work on that, I need you to retrieve some prototype parts.
Carefully, I suggest you go during the day.
I wouldn't want to be out on the reef at night.
Is there anything else?
No?
Okay.
I sleep?
I've been in love with you since Shadow Moses.
Okay, Otacon.
Alrighty.
Is that a quote straight from the Mufasa movie?
I don't remember.
They do talk about the circle of life.
But he talks about how he thinks the circle of life is stupid.
And he also was just like, she lives in you.
Like, um...
I don't know what you're talking about, buddy.
Alright, let's grab our stuff.
Look on the equipment table on the table.
Prototype parts.
Okay.
Anything... I don't think there was anything else.
Oh!
No, no, no, no, wake up, wake up!
Wake up!
They were waking, waking, waking, waking...
Wiggle, wiggle, wiggle, wiggle, wiggle...
Wiggle, wiggle, wiggle...
Wake up, wake up, wake up!
I... have no space.
Could you make this three times smaller?
Okay.
Connected to the researcher's outpost generator.
Take a look at the list of specimens.
Remember, you'll want to install and activate the machine before attempting to collect these.
You might also need to improve that equipment I gave you to catch some of these.
Okay!
Yay!
I'm sure some of these we don't have... I mean...
Okay.
Let's...
So about that research...
Alright!
Welcome to Bamboo Ship.
Thank you!
So...
My crabs are going crazy!
That's not a crab!
He's having...
Identity issues.
To the generator.
In a moment.
First I'm gonna sell all my fish.
Look at that guy!
He's crazy looking!
Stinging spiked tentacles.
Trail of love.
Do you think maybe we should have... Well, obviously we have to have her install it.
It's just...
We have to get rid of our oceanic it seems.
Wait.
Actually...
Not research.
Floating dock.
Even that would not be enough.
Why is it like this?
Why can't you both be on the same side?
There's a better one you can research?
Well, yeah, I mean...
There's a lot of things I can research.
This is so stinky.
But also, I have no research point, so I can't even research.
It's just how it is.
Oh wait, I can research more stuff after I...
After I install it?
Wait, let me see.
Oh, there it is!
OK, we just gotta get one.
We just gotta get one!
But it's huge!
It takes up...
It takes up the whole thing?
Shiny in the distance.
Shiny still in the distance.
Mist in the distance!
Stinking mist man.
Nonononononono!
Please leave me alone!
The slowest docking ever.
Turn off your lights near the fog?
Is that how that works?
You don't need to equip it to open research.
I mean, I did just then.
It didn't let me before.
I'm just gonna sleep.
I'm gonna sleep.
Whatever.
Undock.
Alright, now we go back.
One moment please.
Blue crab!
Isn't that a rare?
Good morning, Minto.
Before we do this, I want to...
There is some over here, you know.
I want to see what's over in this direction.
About these guys right here.
These guys right here.
Where are you leading me?
This thing is...
Icky.
P.N.
Do you guys remember that game?
I don't think I ever played it though.
Alright, what's that thing?
Giant Amphipod!
Oh my god, so cute!
Snail fish.
I do need this though, to catch the snail fish in the Amphipod.
No!
Oh my god.
Can I just...
Lady, why didn't you...
You wouldn't have been able to do your own research.
Never heard of it?
It was the...
It was like a horror meme game where you played...
You ran away from a guy with a P.N.
face.
Like the...
And he just chased you.
And it goes, P.N.
Oh wait, there's the guys I need here.
Anglerfish.
Check the fishing spot behind you.
This one?
But I can't get into this one though.
Wait, this is... Oh, this one?
Right here?
I can't do it yet.
Why I still hear a dog?
There's a game like that where you have to stop possessed idle otaku.
I feel like I've played that game before.
That groper was abyssal.
Too bad.
It's okay.
Hello ma'am.
Yo fish.
We got a lot of red snapper.
And a blood snapper.
Blood leaks endlessly from under its scales, pooling beneath it no matter where it's placed.
So metal.
When looking for someone to possess, do you single out idle otaku?
Not quite.
Really just what I'm in the mood for.
You know?
Sometimes idle otaku taste yummy in their life force.
But ultimately all otaku have poor diets.
Likes a little bit of variety.
What's in here?
Wait.
Our blue crab is stale.
I should sell him, huh?
The call out.
It's okay.
I'm an otaku too.
I have bad eating habits too.
Glistening.
This thing looks so Junji Ito-esque.
Glistening purple strings sprout from solid rock, tying and untying themselves.
They fall away and wither, making way for new knots.
So wait.
It's not even a crab.
It's a rock?
Guys, we have so much money now.
We are making bank.
We have $2,000.
$2 ,000.
If only I had cloth.
$2,000 and not enough money to buy a dang cloth.
I also... Oh wait.
You know what?
I'm buying the research part.
Screw it.
Fathomless winch.
Fishing speed 82%.
She did have another one.
You know what?
I'm going to buy it because why not?
I have a lot of money.
And I'm going to use it towards this bad boy.
Winch my beloved.
I'm going to use it towards that bad boy.
I think if you have this and this, that's all you need, no?
Technically.
No room for net.
Yeah, you would have to get rid of the net.
So sad.
Oh, we're almost getting over it.
We're almost done getting over it.
Yeah.
What was I doing?
Oh, let's sleep.
And then...
I forgot to buy the...
I forgot to buy it and install it.
I like to install the stuff at night.
You know?
So that...
I can...
Not worry about it.
Four hours!
I was so aggressive.
Wake up!
We got another blue crab.
Very cute.
I guess I have this thing in my inventory.
Time to cause a panic.
What did I get?
10% chance to not reduce fish stocks when catching a fish with a rod.
One moment.
I can research here.
Generator.
A researcher's repulsion machine could be connected to an outpost generator.
There you go.
A small object rolls out.
Activate the machine.
Wait, hold on.
Not right now.
Research!
Oh my gosh.
OK.
Activate.
Yes.
The repulsion machine hums in words to life.
A few seconds later, a bright light shoots from the top and an alarm begins blaring.
The researcher says this should keep the creature at bay for a time at least.
I mean, or attack is what she said.
Really depends.
Oh, he's gone.
This is it, right?
Wait.
I'll probably have to pay for more if I screw this up.
Is this it?
Which one's it?
What the hell are you?
Giant amphipod.
There it is.
I see it.
We did it!
Ew.
It's so slimy.
Keep going.
Is this like a blobfish, you think?
It's kind of loud and annoying.
Wait a second, what's this?
Is it starting to stir again?
Oh, sorry.
That scared me.
I think he's coming too.
I thought it was showing me that he's coming too.
Oh, this thing.
I took too many blobfish.
Wait, we can move this around.
Easy peasy.
Easy mode.
Nice.
This way.
Run?
I'm running.
We're getting out.
Oh no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Please leave me alone.
I hate the mist.
It's so annoying.
About those specimens.
I got two of them.
Why did I get so many of these guys?
And no other amphipods.
I have good news and bad news.
The bad news.
The bad news is that the samples you retrieved from the basin have dangerously high counts of cellular mutations.
Wait, what?
The good news is that I've honed in on what's causing the abnormalities in the ecosystem.
This all points to one thing.
That thing in the basin is harmful to the life at a cellular level.
It damages everything around it, whether passively or with intent.
I need to write up a report on my findings.
Sorry, our findings.
Immediately.
Maybe now they'll take me seriously.
How rude of me.
You've done all this for me and I've not got much to say thank you with.
You should have this.
Wait, what about the good news?
Plan for the future.
Thank you.
Sleep.
Oh no, the fish!
They're still fresh.
All I have to do is hurry.
Hurry back home.
Not home.
You know what I meant.
Make haste.
Boost.
They're still fresh.
Can
I grab this thing too?
A little crab.
Nice.
Oh, even turning around I got a new fish.
Okay.
How are they?
My fish?
They're stale.
They're stale, but still worth money.
Alright, let's undock.
Let's teleport.
I thought we got bamboozled for a second.
That it just blew up my entire ship.
You walk in and place the jewel-encrusted ring on a table by the collector.
His eyes widen.
We're certainly making excellent progress now.
And I know what you're thinking.
An item like this would fetch a fortune at any auction.
But for us, it's value transcends material wealth.
I mean it sort of did.
Yeah, but you know what I meant.
Regardless, you are due a reward.
Alright, he's going to speak.
Vanish.
You hear a growling.
Crackling in your ears.
Suddenly your vision flares and both of your ears pop.
He closes the book.
We must keep searching.
I've been thinking more on where we might find another.
I can imagine all manner of detritus swallowed by the silty muck of twisted strands channels.
It's worth investigating.
I'll mark a location on your map where you can begin your search.
Why am I going crazy?
Oh yeah, what did you do to me?
What is this?
Vanish.
Temporary protection from most things.
If spoken swiftly enough, they can be used defensively.
Choose their moment carefully.
The more they are spoken, the more they are understood.
Oh, teleporting does that.
What will you do once you have all the relics?
He ponders for a moment.
It's surprising, isn't it?
The attachments we hold towards simple objects.
But they are anything but simple.
Seemingly mute articles can speak in different ways.
If I showed you a childhood toy, you would be awash with forgotten memories.
They hold the power to recall what was once lost.
Anything else?
Nah, I'm going.
I just wanna make money.
I'm here to fish and... fish?
Oh, I don't have oceanic anymore.
Like Ratatouille?
Good morning, Mintao.
Woke up and you're still playing.
I haven't been playing for that long.
Did you get like 2 hours of sleep?
Thank you.
And storage.
So, can I sell these?
No, I can discard them, but...
Okay, thank you.
Bye bye.
It's been 6 hours.
That's not enough time to sleep, though.
Matthew, thank you so much for the 10k.
Thank you.
Oh, a lighthouse keeper approaches you on the dock wearing a questioning expression.
You must have been around most of the islands by now.
Have you found whatever it is you're looking for?
I'm just fishing.
She recoils from your flagrant lie.
Why do you mistrust me so?
What have I done to warrant such suspicion?
She turns from you, shaking her head and muttering.
She heads back towards the light... I mean, it's true, though.
I am just... I am!
Fathomless whinge.
I guess I could sell this.
Whistle.
Oceanic.
Yeah.
I'll unsell.
Daniel.
In.
Purchase.
I have to get up for work in 4 and a half hours.
Please go to sleep.
Please, please, please.
And we'll repair everything.
Shiny, bright and new.
Awesome.
I'm just here for the fish, ma'am.
It's true.
I'm just here for the fish.
Nice.
Is she doing the good ending route?
I don't know what I'm doing at all.
I'm playing the game.
I'm just playing the game.
We have so much scrap.
I'm not intending for any sort of ending, though.
I'm just going along with it.
I guess we can get... We can sell this hydraulic rod, huh?
Yeah, we don't need that.
That's much cleaner.
I want the rest of the treasure map.
The other things, like these?
I guess I can.
Like the weak valve engine.
I guess I can sell it.
There we go.
Wow, it's so tidy.
Relics, cults, ancient horrors beyond my comprehension?
Man, I don't know nothing about that, but check out this funny 12-tailed fish I just got.
It's literally how I'm feeling about this entire game.
Out of the watch on a ship to watch mint on a ship.
Cheerios!
Welcome to membership, thank you!
Alrighty.
Actually, the one place he's telling us to go to next, we have not been to before, so that's exciting.
Oh, I've been finding relics for the collector.
Relics collector?
I'm not sure what you're hoping to achieve with this character.
Do I even know?
Have you stopped to consider it?
Fish.
Funny fish.
Something about horrors beyond my comprehension?
This one might have three eyes.
Oh!
It has five eyes!
Wait a second though, what were we supposed to find for that one guy?
Uh-oh, he's probably starving over there.
A fangtooth.
Fangtooth.
Never heard of her.
Vanish.
It's an abyssal fish.
Oh, I see, I see.
What was I doing?
Oh, I was gonna go sell these guys real quick.
And then maybe I'll go find some abyssal fish.
Hello!
In fact, I am gonna buy another crab pot.
Where can we find some abyssal fish that I haven't gotten before?
Or, you know what I mean.
I'm gonna put it here.
Scare away spooky fish?
There are none.
Every fish loves me.
I can't see in the dark.
Okay, I'm gonna go turn the lights on.
I can't see where the deep fish will be at.
Did you just call me monkey?
Monkey?
It's not monkey, it's Minky!
It's not my name.
Let's go find some abyssal fish.
Are you?
Coastal?
Where?
We're in like the middle of the ocean.
Return to monkey.
Same thing!
Hi monkey!
Look at that!
Look how much more room we have!
Amazing!
A loose jaw.
I've gotten that guy though.
What is that?
Bronze whaler.
Looking for a new and exciting fish.
Yeah, hot dog.
Little mackerel.
Wait, another sailfish.
Thanks for keeping me company while I work today.
What?
That's not my name!
My name is Mint Phantom, but you can also call me Minto or Minky.
And if you call me anything else...
You owe me...
Much.
Mint Toad.
I choose you, Minky.
I'm not a Minky.
What about Little Lady?
Minto, what if we called you Q?
I made chat...
I thought I had haste.
I'm so glad.
Minto.
A bearded mackerel.
Getting better.
Look at the cyclone.
For real.
Now you might be wondering, why are you back here, Minto?
Because there might be abyssal fish.
I don't know.
I'm just here.
Almost $400.
Sailfish are insane.
Where do you want to go for lunch, Nerdo?
This is Minko.
That's so funny!
Guys, I'm going to give you identity crisis.
Dolphin.
What's that?
Perch.
Tiger.
Abyssal fish.
Ok, let's go back to our little friend.
The guy that's hungry.
And maybe... Maybe it's an abyssal thing close to him.
Maybe?
I don't know anymore.
What are you?
Oceanic fish that I have not caught.
Wait, I do want to put that on.
Sturgeon.
That's kind of awkward.
Nashi!
Thanks for the five gifted!
Oh, there's no fish.
I have to play that.
In Minto's world, bullies give her money.
It is illegal to assert that your name is not Freak Phantom.
Ok, but that's like...
We gotta be really good buddies for you to call me that.
One does not just call someone a freak.
Without it being an act of love.
Oh, there's wood over there.
Getting dark.
I know, I know, I know.
Where's all the abyssal fishies at?
The Minky Momo!
No!
Rest.
Might be a night fish.
Maybe.
And here I am waking up.
Let's see.
You call us freaks all the time.
You said what I said.
What's this?
Our little friend is in that little cove over there.
So let's see.
Research!
And whatever that thing is!
Research first!
Is this the research?
Yes!
Yay!
New fish located.
Yeah, where was he?
Right there.
Forward!
Straight!
That guy right there.
Wait, what are you?
Oh, you!
Oh, there's so many new fish.
New fish!
Exciting!
This is exciting everybody.
It's me!
It's a me!
Mito!
I think this thing is definitely the tiger.
No!
Oh my gosh!
It's a bear alive!
Okay,
I gotta be careful of the time.
Because I do not know where... Oh wait, is that a dock right there?
Is that a workable dock?
Some more dredge.
Some more dredge for my boss Mito.
Thank you.
Where
is your fish mister?
Is it maybe really a night fish?
It could be.
It could be a night fish.
Let's dredge here.
Sapphire earrings.
Oh it's dark.
I will fish by...
Wait, where am I going?
Wrong way.
This way.
And also this thing.
Molly Phantom from the Four Kids Dog.
What is that from?
Who is she actually?
I'm looking for any disturb...
What is this?
I'm drifting?
Where is all my... Where is all my super cool...
Abyssal fish at?
Are you coming close?
I can't tell.
But I want this thing.
I don't care.
I want it!
What are you?
Oh, nevermind.
I think I have you.
No, I don't have you.
Scouring bash.
I feel more fine without the stinking mist around.
Look at them.
There is two of them.
I can't tell if they move when I move or if they...
You know?
Oh, they definitely look like they are getting closer.
Fish market.
185.
It did say that I could dispel, but does it work on... I don't know what it works.
Does it work on... It said it doesn't work on everything.
They chase you.
Let's head back over to that area.
Maybe we can get some abyssal fish.
Excuse me.
What's that?
I don't like that.
What is that?
What does that mean?
What do the eyeballs mean?
I see.
Oh, I didn't do the fish.
You are right.
I didn't do the fish.
In the...
Behind the waterfall.
Yes, thank you for reminding me.
I did not get that guy.
Indiana Jones ass music.
Wait, this way?
And I won't crash into it either.
What's this?
Wait, it might be a new one though.
New variant?
Boring to kid.
I missed it.
It was so tiny.
Sorry.
Four fish acquired.
So close.
My fancy fishing.
Can I get this thing here now?
Is this guy like patrolling?
I don't ever know how...
When he comes out.
Why he comes out.
For whom he comes out.
Like I know when I pass by that area.
One single doubloon.
I wonder if my thing works on him.
My banish.
He has a patrol route.
What is this?
More scrap?
Yeah.
I did notice that.
Oh my gosh.
We are going to be able to do all the research ever in the world.
Holy cow.
Is this normal?
I got
to maneuver some stuff around a bit.
There we go.
Oh.
Night time.
I don't think I can fit anymore though.
Did it work?
Oh, it's gone.
OK, you can stop now.
Oh.
That was something.
And then, don't sell the fish.
Yes, we are not going to sell... How much did he go for?
I'm just curious.
300.
Almost.
And as part of our thing, catch rare fish.
Report ore fish.
Oh, I just have to tell her.
Hello!
I found an ore fish.
That's great news.
Add it to my records.
Here, take this.
I can sell it.
Nevermind.
Here you go, ma'am.
What should we research now?
We have four.
Guys, we have four research parts.
We could do engines or...
We could do nets.
Oh yeah!
The heavy duty net.
Yes, yes, yes, you're so right.
Thank you for reminding me.
I'm so excited.
Heavy duty.
I should repair this one first.
I sold everything in it.
680.
We can afford.
We're gonna be making big ol' bucks, everybody!
We're gonna be rich!
Rich, rich, rich!
Oh my gosh.
We've got all the best... What's these ones?
Oh, mangrove and then volcanic.
I see, I see, I see.
I see, I see, I see, I see.
Should I even try for... Well, I guess I can't.
I have to do these other engines first.
This one looks insane.
I want to try it so bad.
Get the rods first.
Yeah, you're right.
Back to rod.
Why do I keep rushing escape?
What else we got in here?
Encyclopedia.
Our special guy, the oarfish.
He doesn't have any aberrations.
He's special.
I'm sorry, $250.
Mine was like $249.
I got robbed.
Got robbed out of a dollar.
Not the crab pot.
Deploy!
My net.
Yeah, I got robbed of my single dollar.
I guess let's go to the...
Next place then.
To the twisted strand.
Ooh, scarlet prawn.
Yeah, this way.
Scammed a whole dollar.
Yeah, yeah.
I said what I said.
Oh my gosh, that scared the heck out of me.
Hello whale.
What if this is the thing that we need?
Tiger!
Viperfish.
I've also been called that.
How do I find the stinking tigerfish?
Can I get a hint if anybody looks it up?
If anybody googles it, give me a hint.
Barely.
Viperfish.
Under the sea.
Stellar basin?
Really?
We have to go back there?
It's in the water.
What am I going over here for?
Oh, I was just gonna go sell some stuff real quick.
Check my crab...
Crab legs.
Okay.
Hot dog indeed.
Let's go sell all this crab.
Man, these people are eating good!
Why does the twisted strand make me think of Outer Wilds?
I understand.
It makes me think of Twisted Pear.
Which is Neil Breen.
Sell all fish.
Alright.
Thank you, sir.
Dark bramble vibes.
Truly, yeah.
So if I need to go back to...
The stellar basin.
Anchovy!
Little anchovy.
And I mean, there are anglerfish in here.
That's very bramble.
Oh, let's see what we got.
Oh, whoops.
My bad.
Tab.
What was it?
The future?
Oh.
15% chance to not reduce fish stocks when catching a fish with a rod.
I see.
It's so quiet here.
Anchovy king!
Holy moly.
Trophy!
What are these guys?
Oh, it's these guys.
Okay.
Maybe here?
These look like anglerfish though.
Music here is so spooky.
What are you?
More anglerfish?
What does it even look like?
I should probably... Hold on.
Let's check the...
Let's check the pursuit.
Oh, it doesn't show me a picture.
No!
Don't get angry, please.
I'm just a weasel.
I'm just a measly little fisherman.
Oh wait, I'm on the wrong side.
It's small?
Use the scope.
If it's small...
Can I get this guy?
Gulper eel!
That thing is so gross.
Wait, that's not like a rare fish, is it?
Not a relic.
It's a rare fish.
Gulper eel!
Oh my gosh, it is!
I got it!
That was so easy.
That was way easier than the other one.
Why was that one so much easier?
Hey lady!
Nothing in my crabs.
Easiest rare fish is just hanging out.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying!
Hello lady.
Do I get two more researchers?
That's great news.
Oh my god, I do!
What?
I got all the information I need.
Now we...
I don't have anything I need to store.
Just sell.
500!
100!
Wow.
We're just printing money at this point.
Goodness gracious.
I guess I'll rest.
I can't tell if this thing is...
If this thing I'm looking for is a...
A fishy that should be at night or awake or what.
Still no cloth.
Oh yeah.
Yeah, still no cloth.
What's this?
These look like they're just little fish.
What are you?
You know what?
I'll take some wood.
You want an actual hint?
Yes, I would love an actual hint.
I would love an actual hint because I...
I want to complete that quest.
It's around here at any time.
Look for red eyes in the water.
Oh, I know where that is though.
These guys.
There's...
But these are like this... I always get this guy.
I thought it was this.
The loose jaw.
Maybe there's some more.
Bangtooth are more towards the outside of the map.
Are you just saying that to get me to go towards the outside of the map and then something's gonna eat me?
Feels like a Subnautica situation.
And then
these guys are the angler fish.
Are you looking for tiger mackerel or goliath?
Tiger mackerel.
I'm looking... I want to complete...
This... No!
Fangtooth!
It's not a tiger mackerel at all.
It's a Fangtooth.
I want to complete this quest.
You
might be on top of it.
No, I'm not.
These are angler fish.
What about over here?
Oh wait!
Could it be?
A Fangtooth!
Fang!
I
think I could... Wait.
Oh no, I'm going inside.
If we go around... I think we can deliver it to him.
We finally found it.
No!
You will not whisper sweet nothings into my ear.
Now I don't know where he is.
Wait!
Oh my god!
I know where he is.
Mister!
Sorry I kept you waiting, huh?
Here you go.
They bring this small fish up to their mouth and bite at where the heart is.
Their cracked lips part to reveal a row of sharpened teeth.
Sense an opening.
They unfurl the final scroll.
Oh crab!
Hi, hi, hi.
What the?
Guys, what is that?
It's a ghost ship.
No, foghorn!
Scary!
It's a rare event, really?
I'm scared.
Go say hi.
I've already dealt with two ships!
It's big.
Oh it's gone.
Wait.
And...
I'll sleep here.
Hello photographer lady.
I hope you don't mind if I just...
That was so cool!
Oh I used up all my resources.
Good night!
I scared him.
Well I guess we know who the better ghost is.
You know, not everyone can be as terrifying and...
You know, as spooky as I and everything.
I'm just saying.
Oh that's where her camera was.
Alrighty, we're back here because I know we can get some blue crab.
And we're just collecting fish on the way.
We're making bank.
Oh crackers!
Julius, thank you so much for the raid!
Thank you, thank you.
Welcome everybody.
We're playing dredge.
It's a game where you fish and nothing creepy happens.
Ignore that.
Alright, I think we need to fix my little crab gun.
My pot.
Pick up.
Paper bags!
Thanks for the gift dude!
Thank you, thank you.
Fish?
Market.
First we gotta sell my fish.
I picked up some creepy guys.
Some creepy crawlies.
And then we're gonna repair everything.
Check your net before selling.
Maybe you caught some...
Oh crabs?
I don't think you can catch crabs in your net, can you?
I never have.
Nashi!
Thank you for the farm gift dude!
Lockstech, welcome to membership.
Thank you, thank you guys.
Let's see.
Large crab pot.
Release!
Alright, now we just chill around here.
Oh, store my wood.
Wait, do I still have it?
Oh, you're right!
Thank you for letting me know.
Thank you, thank you.
Let's go get some... There were some other... Where those red eyed fish were, there were some other abyssal stuff.
We can maybe see if...
Something's hungry.
That's totally me.
Oh, I thought I saw a disturbed water.
Loose jaw.
Angler fish.
Barracuda.
Red snapper.
Gosh, how are we so good at seeing?
We are like the most experienced fisher ever.
We can see their swim patterns and we're like, we know what that is.
We know what that is!
Easy peasy.
Is that cloth?
No!
Unfortunately, it was...
It was wood.
Can
you fish ducks here?
Asking for a friend who wants to be fished by a cute ghost.
There's no ducks in these waters.
What if there used to be ducks in these waters?
No crab yet.
I'm just gonna wander around a little bit.
Maybe we'll catch something.
I don't think I've been around this side actually.
I haven't really seen this area.
Or maybe I have.
Maybe I don't want to.
Leave me alone!
I don't want the whispers.
Anchovies are so cute.
So itty bitty.
This will sleep.
Blue crab.
Yes!
Go home.
We need this guy for a quest.
Ignore everything else.
What are the stones for?
I still don't know that yet.
Wood is cute.
The crab is pretty cute.
He's about to get his heart ripped out though.
Catch 150 fish in trawl net.
No, it is over here.
Minky is cute.
Telling lies?
No papa.
Open your mouth.
Sense an opening.
Here's your crab.
They crack and bend the crab's legs apart and feast on the flesh inside.
Lips still covered in crab flesh, they take a book from inside their robe and hand it to you.
Answer given.
We await summons.
They cross their arms and appear to fall into a deep sleep.
Advance fishing.
I'm a fisherman.
This is related to me.
Lazuli!
Thank you for the raid!
Hello, hello, hello!
Wait, didn't you just debut?
Congratulations!
He's trying to be more very cute.
Stupid.
Hello, hello!
Peachy, peachy raid.
So cute.
Mervy, thanks for the fun game!
I just noticed there's like other robes there.
Does he change or are those his friends?
Did he eat them?
I have so many questions.
Alrighty.
I'm gonna remove the marker.
This one too.
Kevarin, thanks for the 5 gifted!
Tenshi, thanks for the 5 gifted!
Jay, thanks for the 5 gifted!
Thank you guys.
Chibarin, thank you for the 5 gifted!
There are 5 robe guys to find.
Tenshi himself, thanks for the 5 gifted!
Thank you guys, thank you!
Well, we have...
I still have not gone to the strand yet.
Or the devil's spine.
I think I might save them for next time!
ShadyNoctis, thanks for the 5 gifted!
Ball, thanks for the 5 gifted!
Kaze, thanks for the 5 gifted!
Thank you guys so much, so many gifted people!
Please, thank you!
Thank you so much!
No over ending?
Yeah, I think so.
Takizo, thanks for the 5 gifted!
50MT, thank you for the 5 gifted!
Oh my gosh, Fireball, thank you for the 5 gifted!
Grapple, thank you for the 5 gifted!
Thank you guys, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
It's only been 7 hours.
I know.
I have a meeting though.
Meep, thanks for the gifted!
I have a meeting.
In about 2 hours, I wanna eat.
Vectorsome, thanks for the 10 gifted!
Oh my gosh, Unlucky Bison, thanks for the 10 gifted!
Dexterian, thank you for the 5 gifted!
Jamie Baxter, thanks for the 5 gifted!
Nekos, thanks for the 5 gifted!
Tetsutani, thank you for the 5 gifted!
Oh my gosh.
I have a meeting with some tacos.
I hope that's what my other meeting is too.
Ms. Belchat, thank you for the 5 gifted!
Swordabushido, thank you for the 5 gifted!
LK Hetzel, thank you for the 5 gifted!
Rusty Glitchface, thank you for the gifted!
Chidon-chan, thank you for the 10 gifted!
John, thank you for the...
Thank you for the first 10 gifted!
Paktime, thank you for the 10 gifted!
Thanks for the chill Sunday, Minko!
Thank you!
Thank you, welcome back, Raiti!
You can't leave!
I'm hungry!
So many gifts.
Thank you, welcome back, Digita!
Duargo, thank you for the...
Superchat!
Almost a gifted.
Make sure to nom on extra life energy from us.
Until we feel completely better.
Okay, okay!
I will.
Thank you for the 10 gifted!
Thank you!
Thank you for the superchat!
Salty0, thanks for the superchat!
Katsu, thanks for the 10 gifted!
Oh my gosh, there's so many!
You guys!
Paperback, thanks for the superchat!
Thanks for keeping us company today!
Of course!
Biosenshi, thank you for the 5 gifted!
Oh, I just said your legal name.
Thanks for the gifted!
Shag, welcome back!
Shadow Demon Lord, welcome back!
Laughing Man, welcome back!
Thank you guys.
Okay.
Thank you for...
Thank you for the sleep.
Good night!
Andricus, thanks for the 5 gifted!
Ashenslaw, thank you for the 5 gifted!
Jcriber, thank you for the 5 gifted!
Thank you, thank you!
Cole, welcome back!
Deuce, thanks for the 5 gifted!
Bismuth, thank you for the 10 gifted!
Shadow Demon Lord, thank you for the gifted!
This feels like a superchat wrap almost.
WakeupBlock, thank you for the 5 gifted!
ElectricSakes, thank you for the 5 gifted!
There's so many!
Okay, I'm gonna go.
I'm gonna go so I can eat!
And get ready and everything!
Hi Minky!
Hello!
Sular, welcome back!
Thank you!
Andrew, thank you for the superchat!
You are out of this world.
Yeah, I'm extra... no.
I'm supernatural!
Supernatural!
Johnny, thank you for the 5 gifted!
Tiara, thank you for the gifted!
Otamito, everybody!
Thank you so, so, so, so, so much!
I like dredge a lot, just a little bit.
And we made some crazy progress today, no?
EpicGamerDog, welcome back!
Ph, thank you for the 5 gifted!
Thank you!
It was a lot of fun.
I hope you guys had a nice chill Sunday or whatever time it is for you.
And, yeah!
Otamito!
I'll see you guys when I see you!
I just arrived!
Wait, that's actually so funny.
I was just thinking about...
When a streamer...
You could try this with...
If you follow any Japanese Vtubers or Japanese streamers When they're ending, you can be like...
Kita bakari!
It means, I just got here!
When they're ending.
Kita bakari!
It means, I just got here!
Ki, not hita.
Ki, ki, ki...
Kita bakari.
That's your Japanese lesson for today.
Bakari is when you say...
You use it when it's something very recent.
Or something that...
Happens often.
Or a lot.
So it's like...
If you're just like...
If someone says, do you want to go eat spaghetti?
And you're like, ah, spaghetti!
Tabeta bakari!
Then it's like, oh, I just ate spaghetti.
So maybe not that, you know?
And then, kita.
Kuru is like...
To arrive.
Wakarimashita.
That's your Nihongo lesson.
It's pretty useful.
Benri na Nihongo da to omoimasu.
Bakari desu.
You'll hear it quite often.
Spaghetti-chan.
Who's that?
Mito suki bakari.
Benkyou ni narimashita.
Okay, awesome Mito.
Thank you guys.
Itterashai.
Bye bye.
Thank you.
How do I save?
Where do I...
There's not in the menu.
How do I save?
Where am I?
Wait, I'm gonna go here and save.
At the dock.
Okay.
Thanks, bye.
Bye.
What was that?
Okay, thanks, bye.